Three. Two, one. Here we go. How are you sir? I'm doing good. Um,
I'm super happy to have you here. If there is a mount Rushmore of video games,
you are George Washington, you're up there. So this is great.
People have been kind of nudging us from years and years to get this done.
So it's great that we're finally able to make it happen. Yeah. Um,
I have been from day one a gigantic quake junkie and a doom junkie.
So for me to have you in here is a giant treat and everybody,
you know I've talked about your video games and your creations so many times on
this podcast. So it's,
it's very cool to have you here and thank you very much for showing me before
the podcast got started.
I should tell her buddy you showed me the latest and greatest version of Oculus
rift, which is amazing. It's so small for people watching the youtube.
This is the entire unit. This, this thing that sits on your head.
It's very light and it's not attached to a computer.
Like you don't have to carry anything around and there's no extra,
everything is in here. Yeah. So this is the oculus quest, the standalone device,
and it's been kind of the culmination of a bunch of different products that
we've been working on and it's the vision that we had even six years ago.
Just the idea of not connected to anything.
You put this magic hat on and you're transported to these different worlds and
this is available right now. Anyone can buy this. Right? Okay.
So it's available. Jamie just actually pulled up the website. Um,
can I push this up to you? Pull it? Yeah. There you go. Um, how,
what is the battery life on these things? So it depends on what you're doing.
Where I, if you just sit there and watch Netflix, I, you know,
it'll last a little more than three hours.
If you play some of the really hardcore games,
it might only last two hours or so.
Do you have numbers on how many people are watching Netflix on this thing?
So our previous one right before this,
the oculus go was a little bit more media focused.
And that's one of our more popular applications. I mean, surprisingly things,
everybody thought that VR was going to be all about these just amazing gaming
experiences,
but some of the most popular experiences are doing reasonably conventional
things. Watching Netflix, watching youtube, Amazon prime,
stuff like that where if you're like, if you're you,
when you've got a great home theater and everything,
there's not this much benefit to having a theater like that in VR.
But if you're in a situation like you're in a tiny room in Tokyo or something,
the idea of being able to put on the VR headset and have this like lovely ski
lodge atmosphere with a giant screen TV, it has some real benefits.
So in the end,
VR should be a replacement for anything you do on screens today,
whether it's your phone, your tablet, your TV, your laptop, your PC,
all of these should eventually be superseded by just having more flexible
screens in VR. I mean,
we have lots of challenges now with resolution and comfort for longterm use,
but this is the direction that everything's going.
Not only do you have things in VR that you couldn't do anywhere else,
just experiences that you can't have with that level of immersion,
but it should pull along every other thing that people do with screens,
devices today. Uh, that's, I didn't consider the television shows,
but of course people
would be watching Netflix on this if it's possible.
Have you done the Disney world ride the Avatar ride flights of passage now?
I haven't done that yet. It's amazing you sit on this,
it's like a motorcycle looking thing.
It straps you in place and it's supposed to represent one of those flying dragon
things and Avatar. And then you have the headset. You put that on.
And the VR virtual reality experience is second to none. I mean,
it's incredible. Super high resolution and the, the motorcycles moving around,
you get wind and smells and all these, uh, sensories.
So that's one of the really interesting things.
I think about that whenever I am at amusement parks for things like the Harry
Potter rides and stuff like that where they're doing lots with screens and
motion platforms where I think about it from the VR perspective and anything
we're doing visually and audibly,
we could go ahead and do a great job in the headset.
So it's cutting it down to these few physical things that you can't do.
So you've got things with motion platforms that actually jostle you around that
you can't do in VR.
You've got things like smell and like the void I'm where they had the star wars,
uh, experienced there. We have a fantastic star wars experience on quest,
which in many ways has a lot of that magic,
but in the void where they set it up and they blow hot air over,
what's the virtual lava I towards you?
That's something that you still don't get,
but it's kind of like the the age old battle of what can you do differently in
an arcade that you can't do as good in your eye,
your home system and VR now takes,
lets you do all of these amazing things there.
But if you're willing to spend millions of dollars and build a theme park
attraction essentially, you can still throw some of these extra things.
And people joke about when is smellovision coming to VR.
And there have actually been real companies that have spun up to say it's like,
oh we want to do scent, augment mentation. But it's not a great thing.
And those are still the last vestiges of things where you have to go someplace.
But the promise of VR is to, you know, the world as you want it.
Not Having to go to someplace to do something magical.
And if you can get to 90 something percent of that experience staying in your
own room, then that's great. What would they be able to do with smell vision?
Would you have like a standalone unit that like has access to the program?
So like if you were flying over orange fields, it would spray citrus in the air.
So sort of like soaring over the world. Have you ever done that Disneyland ride.
So they let somebody who literally did make this where they made a little box
that put I that glute or attached to the underside of the head mounted display.
And one of the interesting things about scent as opposed to I like audio or
video with video, everybody knows that you just make red, green and blue colors.
You can mix them in any way and make all the colors that we can see.
Smell isn't like that I,
our nose is actually a receptor for a whole lot of discrete different molecules.
There's no way to mix up smell like the way we do with light to make red,
green and blue primaries with that. So they really had to pick,
okay here's the dozen or so smells that we're going to have with this.
And it would just sort of Spritz it out on a little blast of air. I very close
to your nose so it doesn't need much of it to get in.
So if you really wanted to do some sort of a jungle experience with, you know,
thousands of different smells of plants and dirt and all the,
you would have to have like some enormous unit that spraying these various
things.
Although I suspect that at least modern people in modern society do not really
have that discerning of a level of scent.
Like if you took some Peruvian indigeneity or something that they probably would
complain, it's like, oh, the fidelity on this is garbage.
I should have 500 different smells here and I only detect five. But you take,
you know, a normal city person and you just,
3 cents of jungle is probably going to be more than enough to sell the
experience. The guy in the jungle be like, this is sterile urine. Yeah,
they're not real. So what does this Jamie Homer's,
oh my goodness. So this is something she's holding. She's pulled it off.
It attaches to the headset right here.
It says feel real sensory mask.
So it's a sensory mask that smell virtual reality. Oh yeah.
It's so it stimulates,
simulates hundreds of smells to immerse you in the virtual world.
Wow. Of course it's coming. But why am I shocked? Look at this guy,
he's gotta look a little cartridge.
He's popping in there with all that'll refilling your toner cartridge and you're
out reliable sent generator. How hilarious.
But if you have to rank your senses, it's not in the top two. You know,
and it's probably gonna be clunky,
like the earlier versions of VR where you got that low resolution sort of thing.
I remember my friend Dunkin, uh, he's,
he's a huge technology freak and he had a really early version of the consumer,
uh, virtual reality headsets, uh, the early, early oculus.
And I remember putting it on going, oh my God,
even though it was really pixelated, I'm like, this is a game changer.
Like that sense that you've seen the future. Yeah. You put it on, it's like,
it's not here yet, but that's the,
the ability to just project a little bit past the flaws there and say, okay,
well we're going to sort this out over the next several years.
We'll get higher resolution.
We'll get the response better and you can imagine what it's going to be. Yeah,
it's pretty stunning. And what you just showed me today, the,
the Star Wars one is actually higher resolution than the void,
which is the one that you pay to go see or you go into the warehouse and
everything. I've done that several times.
The void with star wars and in the void with a record Ralph,
which is pretty cool too. It's really fun.
But the physicality of having the actual props there is the magic of being in
there.
It's like you pull out your storm trooper blaster and you have to get around and
that's really something versus a lot of times when you're just using the
controllers to pretend you're doing things,
you feel like you're a mind someplace,
some French mime kind of pretending to do things and that doesn't sell the
experience. And that's why I, you know,
my favorites are the things like beat Saber where in the game you are swinging,
this lightsaber is sort of thing through things.
So your actions in reality are exactly what your actions in the virtual world
are.
You swing through it, there's a little bit of a,
of a buzz as you cross through it and it just feels like you are,
you're projecting yourself there.
Now what about the possibility of a haptic feedback vest or a suit or something
that you can put on your body?
So there's the interesting things all the way back into that.
The doom and quake days. I remember one of the really early,
I kind of entrepreneur guys that came by,
he had made this leather jacket with all of these impact pucks on it and it had,
I had like eight or nine different things that were the solenoids that could
deliver a pretty sharp thud and he wanted to in, you know, get uh,
support added to the Games for that.
The idea you play that and what you're getting when you're getting shot,
it actually feels like you're getting hit in the back. And you know,
I didn't think that was a very likely I am mass market consumer thing. I mean,
not too many people want that level of fidelity where it actually starts making
you sore.
But that's one of the wonderful things about being able to open source the
various codes after the games are a little bit older where anybody that wants to
can nowadays go and take doom or quake or those earlier titles and program in
for whatever crazy thing. They don't have to convince someone.
They don't have to go convince skeptical John Carmack that this device is going
to be a worthwhile thing to add support to the mainline code.
They can just go do it, which is a wonderful thing.
That is very cool that you guys do that I think is really cool and yeah,
that was one of those things where early on as you can imagine,
that was a tough sell in the company where the people that weren't coming from
the sort of hacker ethic background on the programming side,
you get the business people and the artists and the designers and they're like,
we want to just give away our source code.
Won't that be a leg up to the competitors? Why do you want to do this?
And it was one of my, it made me really happy when many years later,
Kevin Cloud, one of my early partners, uh, told me that yeah,
in retrospect that was really the right thing to do and it's great with doom and
quake now especially doing where anything that has a processor runs doom.
If it's got a 32 bit processor and it can conceivably display an image,
people have poured a doom to it and that code will live forever.
A hundred years from now people will be able to dig up and run the doom source
code and some ambulator. That is very cool. Now what was the conversation like?
Like when you guys, when you were saying, hey, this is good for the community,
this is good for games overall, it's going to get people excited about it.
It's just going to generate more business. Like what did you,
how did you sell it?
So it's an interesting path there where in our earliest games,
I can remember that some of the very first things that happened with wolf and
Stein 3d before doom where that was not set up to be easy to be modified.
Uh, we were still back in those days of fitting on floppy disks.
So I had all the data compressed in this nonstandard thing that I just made up
at the time. But people dug through all of that, disassembled the code,
figured out how it worked and started making some level editors and doing the
things like, you know, replacing Hitler with Barney and all of these early mods.
And we're all like, well this is fantastic. You know,
this is people taking the game. They played through the game,
they loved it and they loved it so much that they want to keep doing things on
it and they wind up breaking into the game at that time essentially to figure
out how to make new things. So by the time we were working on doom,
it was an explicit top line technical goal for me that, okay,
I had these graphics things I wanted to do, I want to do networking.
But I also wanted to really make game modding a first top level feature.
So we added all of this ability to do the,
the wads and p Wads and we documented all of it and we released a lot of the
tools, the early source code.
So here's how you go ahead and as much harder at that point with the more
sophisticated stuff going on, but here's how you build a level in doom.
And we even released the code for our level editor,
although that didn't help the community that much because we were using these
crazy expensive next workstations, uh,
and other people had to take the steps to go ahead and make them run on pcs.
But the step beyond that, when we were looking at quake,
I am so I knew that I wanted to enable actual changes of the game play because
in doing, you could swap out all the different models you could swap out. I,
I the way things look,
the way things sounded and some people would go in and actually patch the
executable to do a few minor changes in game play.
But the next step clearly was allowing people to really make whole new game play
modes.
So that was how I quite got this quake c extension language and we wrote a lot
of the game in that and that led to all the things like capture the flag and
team fortress and all those, which was yeah, all these really,
really great things.
But there were still things that you couldn't do or couldn't do effectively
there. And that's where there was still this desire to be able to say,
well what if we just gave them everything?
What if we gave them the full source code and let them sort of hack to their
heart's content port other platforms. And again,
it wasn't a super popular decision, but the way I was pitching it was,
well it still helps our titles. It still gives them life.
It gives them life after they would have been off the shelf falling off of
people's radar, just falling into some game of nostalgia.
But being able to let people make real new versions of it would be,
it would keep them current, it would keep them relevant.
And so the pitch that I ran for years there was after our new game came out with
brand new technology,
then we should be able to open source release the previous generation.
So first when doom was out, we released Wolf Einstein. When quake was out,
we released doom and when the later quakes were out,
we released the quake one code. And that worked out really remarkably well.
I know at the time there were some people in the company that are just like,
this is just John's thing. And they were not really happy about it,
but I was in a position where I could kind of throw my weight around a little
bit, that and I was happy that I did it.
And in the end everybody agrees it was a good win. Um,
I'm a little sad that more companies weren't able to take that final step.
Modding was embraced broadly by a lot of game companies,
but only a handful of companies were able to really go the entire way and
release full source code in the years. That's
too bad because that is one of the core aspects of the quake community is that,
you know,
you guys did release that stuff and there were all these cool extras and things
that you could download and maps.
So many different maps that people had created that were really interesting.
Like I remember one was a guy's apartment. Like you could,
you could play quake in an apartment. Like you could shoot,
you could get to the top of the toilet and shoot it things off the toilet.
It was really amazing.
How did you feel about when people would play the game competitively in the turn
all the textures off?
So I, yeah, that's a,
that especially as a sore point with the artists that have labored for years to
build these glorious textures and then you get the people that just turn them
down. And there's two reasons to turn them down.
You turn them down to help performance. In some cases in the early days,
and especially the early graphics cards,
you would get higher frame rate if you turned him down,
so you'd have less latency in your response times.
But there's also the even more to Pfarius thing about turning them all down to
improve the contrast on your enemy acquisition.
So people want this almost flat shaded world so that any moving set of pixels,
they're just turn and fire at that. And that's, I'm,
I never came to really great terms with that where I always thought on end the
early days of e-sports and gaming,
we did always insist that people have to play with at least plausible
resolutions there because we want our game to look good.
We want people that are looking at it for the first time,
seeing these professionals play it. I am, you know,
we don't want them to look at that and say, well, this game looks like garbage.
It's all flat shaded or blurry. I am.
And luckily computers got fast enough that people could start playing at the
frame rates that they wanted. Even with the full textures running in it. I am,
but the whole pace of doing diet, I kind of,
the East sports and the competitive gaming was very interesting.
We saw the dawn of that with doom, but it's been pretty surprised.
It's been amazing the state that it's taken,
it's gotten to today where I remember when we did the quake read annihilation
tournament,
I gave away my first Ferrari is grand prize and I was thinking this is just the
most over the top thing.
This is going to be unmatched for years and it was only a year later that there
was some other tournament with $100,000 prize coming out. So that went on,
went much quicker than I expected.
And then today you have just the amazing celebrity of the top pro players.
It's a, it's again, it's great to see the path that it's taken. It really isn't.
Yeah,
it's very interesting to see that they're now like legitimate sports stars and
they make a ton of money.
Whereas if you were a kid 10 15 years ago, your parents would tell you,
you're wasting your time. This is nonsense. Why you playing these games?
But now you have a legitimate opportunity to be a professional game player.
Although I do, I get, I hate, there's a hazard there. Where,
what's this Jamie?
What are you pulling up top earners this year compared to the top of tiger
woods? How much do you want in the masters in the top Indy 500 earner?
So Tiger Woods won 2 million in the masters.
The top quake players won 3 million. 121
eight under 72. Well, it's not quick. What game is that? Dota. What does that,
what does that, let's Dodo. It's a different name than quake, but it's a,
it's very popular right now. What's the stand for? I've never even heard of it.
It's a valve game. It's a, it's a Moba,
massively online battle arena game directing all the different little characters
down there. And that along with, especially league of legends, even beyond that,
I not as popular in the United States but is just amazing overseas where,
uh, they, like if you look at the numbers for things, people think, oh,
the super bowl, like the height of all competitive sports, whatever. And they,
a lot of these e-sports games, especially in South Korea are,
they dwarf those numbers really. And some people are just very, yeah,
I'm not aware of this where you just get millions of people tuning in and
enormous arenas too. Right? They play in these gigantic places with,
you look at this, oh my God,
look at this arena that looks like 30,000 people that looks like a UFC event.
Yeah. Yeah. Actually a lot bigger than UFC events. Is that one? Oh,
I'm sure I know about that one in particular,
but they have some really enormous biggest UFC event we ever had was 55,000
people. Yeah, they've been well over that. That's crazy. That's amazing.
It's really cool to see. And it's these games, um,
particularly quake, they are unbelievably difficult to master.
It's one of the more fascinating aspects of like video game play and addiction
is the complexity. Like when you would watch like re like I remember,
do you remember thresh? Oh yeah. Fresh is the one that won my Ferrari first.
Red Annihilation turn to cool.
That guy was the hero back in the day of a early quick play. He was just this,
uh, what does Kenneth Fond, cause I was named Dennis Fong. Dennis fung,
Dennis Fung. Um, there is, there's thresh,
and I remember I would watch demos.
One of the cool things about quake was that you could,
is that as far as one of the fruit, let me see that. Yeah.
So that was my old turbo three Oh eight.
Now you've returned turbocharged your Ferrari's to which I want to get to as
well, which is pretty crazy.
But so this guy was like the first real killer in Dennis fung.
There you go.
First real killer in the quite playing games and you would be able to watch him
play on demos. You play through his eyes.
So you would be able to see like how he does things and move around.
It was really cool.
Some of the interesting things about quake where it wasn't really so clear when
we were designing it, but it is a brutal game,
especially in one-on-one where a lot of modern games are much more approachable.
Where if you followed a lot of the quake games,
a lot of them were just blow outs where you would get somebody that would take
control of the level and they would be running their pattern,
denying anyone any foot in the door and you'd wind up with these 20 to one
blowout games where there are things that you can do in game design to make it
more approachable. Where like if you don't have health packs where you can keep,
because in a game like quake you'd go in as long as you come out on top and the
fight, you've got this little window to run around and bring yourself,
bring your health back up. So even if you're only 5% better,
you might win every engagement because you have enough time to go back,
get yourself back up before you wind up re-engaging.
Where in another game if you didn't have health that I that would continuous,
you had the ability to bring it back up. Then even if somebody didn't win,
if they knocked you down a whole lot then they might get you the next time
around and scores can be much more even quaint gameplay winds up brutal tending
towards blowouts and very frustrating for a,
it did not have the approachability for new players where a lot of more modern
games, things like Overwatch,
I can be jumped into a lot more easily because team play is another aspect of
that where if you've got a team,
you could be on the winning team even if you suck because you might have really
great players that are kind of covering for you there.
You can jump in and have the chance to say, Yay, I won. I am.
Even if you didn't contribute at all and you might wind up, I am, you know,
doing something.
You start off being completely useless and then you slowly work your way up to
being able to contribute effectively for your team.
So I can recognize some of these things now about ways to make games more
approachable, but the kind of brutality of quake,
like there was a a, it was a taste that a lot of people really did.
Like it wasn't so much explicitly designed for that, but it worked out that way.
And that's one of the interesting things as we look at game design today versus
the old days, a lot of people fall into a sort of nostalgia trap about saying,
well, the games I grew up with were the greatest games ever.
And you see it with music and movies and everything.
And I tend to be much more optimistic about the state of things today where the
amount of effort that goes into the modern games is extraordinary.
Just the detail and all the quality on all the different levels.
But there is a little sense of, games are so expensive to make now. You know,
sometimes in the hundreds of millions of dollars that they do have to be
conservative.
So they have to be careful to make sure that they've got something that has a
broad mass appeal. And I think that is the, uh,
the upside of some of the older games where they might have a little bit more of
a distinct flavor.
They weren't sort of focus group to death in the way that some of the more
modern games can be. That's an interesting, you know,
focus group to death I'm sure is a problem. Um, the, the, the quick blowouts,
although that is a thing, um,
it's so fun when you're the person blowing the,
the person out that it's worth learning the maps and that that's the will sort
of people don't understand what we're talking about. Quake would have, um,
well it has maps and on those maps, like this is where the rocket mantra is,
is where the rail gun is, is where the health is.
This is where the mega farmers,
and you had to know where these things were and that they would regenerate every
x amount of seconds. And so you're managing not just you're fighting,
but you're also managing the resources.
So you're running around and trying to control the map and trying to control the
mega health and trying to control where the armor is.
And don't let the guy get the rail gun.
Don't let the guy get the rocket launcher. And in doing that,
it's just incredible of strategy as well as like fast twitch aiming and there's
so many factors going on.
The masters would have at times such that they're just running to where it's
going to spawn and a half second before they get their, it responds,
they run over it, it's there and it's gone.
And the difference between the top level players is something you see in
competitive games a lot even today is you get the sense of the big fish in the
small pond. You know, it's like I am the,
I totally beat all of my friends asses and we're the best.
I'm the best player anybody's ever seen in my tiny little area.
And then you put them in the big pond.
I with some of the professional players and they just, they get nothing.
You know, they wind up not being able to land a shot.
There is that much difference.
Of course you see that in everything martial arts where you get the the Dojo
hero in one place that then goes in and actually rolls with a professional and
just finds out that they weren't all they thought they were.
And there's even more layers of that in games abuse.
You're not so confined to some of the physical limits of the human body. Yeah.
And the amount of time you can do it is not confined to the physical limits of
the human body.
So there's people out there playing 10 12 hours a day with their thinking and
sleeping and dreaming and you know,
catching people with real shots in the middle of the air. Yeah.
That sense when you're obsessive about something,
how it does invade your dreams.
And there've been a number of times in my career when I'm learning new things,
when I'm just immersed in, whether it's a new programming paradigm,
a new piece of technology,
and I'm working 13 something hours in a day and I go to sleep and I have dreams
about what I'm working on.
That's when I know I'm really deep in the groove of soaking in this new
information and the dreaming is my mind helping synthesize this into a useful
form so I can apply this in the future. And those are some things that I,
I look back on very,
very fondly when I've been that obsessive about something that it's soaked into
my dreams. Yeah. I used to get though with martial arts when I was competing,
I would, I would throw kicks in the middle of the night.
I would have like dreams like moving and I'd wake up like, you know,
and like thinking that I was in the middle of the fight and I had a real problem
when we, you know, we have this a land room set up here with quake on it.
And when we got into it where my addiction got re sparked again,
we were playing two, three, four hours a day.
I was starting to have quick dreams. It was really weird.
Like I don't have dreams that I was going down corners and a dodge and rockets
and assist. That game is so immersive and it's so, um,
you get done with it and your heart is pounding like me and Jamie and Jeff would
play. And then when,
when it was over we would all be out of breath with all our heart would be
raced.
We'd have to get up and walk around would be like Jesus tried to shake it off.
That's one of the real interesting things that gets amplified even more in
virtual reality. Where I,
when I was doing a bunch of the work on bringing Minecraft into the gear VR
system, I am, I played a bunch and I would play with my family and it's,
you know,
it's great when you can have your kids playing with you and I would have the VR
headset on that'd be plaguing my swivel chair turning around. I running and I
had this really weird sense where there were times that I would remember that
not as I was playing a game, but I remembered being there.
I remembered like being in that cavern and breaking through into [inaudible]
into a raining sky or I have, you know, having the creeper run up behind me.
And it was not the sense that I remembered playing a video game.
I remembered being there. And that's, that's the power of VR.
And in many ways we don't have as intense of action games like quake in VR,
partially because there's a movement control problem where in VR you're fine as
long as you're moving in the virtual world the same way your body is in the real
world. Uh,
but if you would go ahead and play the traditional game like quake and you were
moving your mouse to spin you around,
you would get really sick to your stomach quickly because, uh,
parts of your inner ear,
I detect motion of your physical body and your brain correlates what your eyes
are seeing with what your inner ear is telling you. And when they disagree,
that's what causes simulator sickness.
Now some of the theories are that that's your brain saying you ate something
that's really bad for you and you should get sick and throw it up.
But this idea that you can't play traditionally like that in VR unless you've
just got an absolute iron stomach. So a things like that,
that they're dashing down corridors flipping around. I am corners,
you don't do very well in VR,
but things where you can either stand still or move sort of in a straight line,
as long as there's no acceleration, the worst things are sort of parabolic arcs.
So rocket jumping and stuff in quake is bad news in VR.
It's still pretty amazing when you go do it, but you do it too many times.
No Way.
You're doing that for a three hour stretch there without having some problems
with it. So what you're saying in terms of the inner ear and the visual,
uh, w w what you're taking individually is that when those things are off,
your brain thinks maybe you consume poison and that's why they're off. Yeah,
that's one of the theories because it makes your stomach upset and people do
throw up sometimes if you've been,
if you've people used to do that even just with traditional video games where I
remember in the early days I, in the early days of quake and doom,
some people would be staring intently enough at the screen and they would get
that sense where on a small monitor it's usually not a problem because I am
usually you see the rest of the stable world around you and the field of view
that you pick.
Like traditionally we used about a 90 degree field of view in the old days and
if you have a little monitor here,
it's really only taking maybe 25 degrees or so of your field of view,
so your brain doesn't really buy it.
As I'm looking into a window in this other world,
you're still kind of controlling something and driving it around.
But when you get a giant screen and you get the field of view about right,
then your brain starts picking up and saying, oh,
maybe I should be paying attention to this visuals.
And that could cause some people to have,
I get simulator sickness even on a screen.
But in VR where it's covering your entire field of view and you don't have a
stable reference, it can be a much bigger problem.
So we have some of these bandaids where people start would put cages of things
in virtual reality, so you've at least got something stable to look at.
And that helps a little bit.
Like there's a game called Omega agent where you're flying around in a jet pack
and on the one hand this is the worst thing to do in VR, parabolic flight.
It checks all the, don't do this in VR buttons,
but it's still really amazingly cool to just jet pack up and kind of coast
around down things. So sometimes you're making these trade offs with your body.
On the VR experiences. I, we try to push people towards the no tradeoff games.
Okay. You can sit here,
you can do this amazing thing and there's no downside to it.
But for the adventurous, there are these other things you can do,
which might be exactly what hits the right buttons for you. But, uh,
you may suffer some for it.
Do you guys take into account the possibility of people getting sick and suing?
Cause I think you kind of have to, right? So there's a lot of,
I what we were more concerned about health and safety wise is on the new system
where you can walk around is, you know, people banging into walls,
falling down steps and so on. So we spent a lot of effort building this.
We call it the Guardian system. When you start up,
you basically trace out what you say, the safe areas, and that's on you.
If you trace out the safe area over your staircase, I am, you know,
bad things can happen. But the ideas that I am, it has a known good area.
It knows where you are. So it will tell you I,
it'll bring up this little overlay to show you that hey,
you're approaching a wall. Do not be charging headlong.
Now people should not be sprinting in VR under almost any circumstances,
but you do wind up getting into the action on things and something jumps sits
behind you, startles you, and you jump around.
So you need a reasonable amount of space to do these.
We call them room-scale games where you're actually walking around.
There's a lot of them that are stationary that you're expected to pretty much
stand still.
But there's some amazing experiences about being able to clear out a room,
walk around and just not be on task as far as hyper aware,
but just being able to soak in a space and kind of crouch down and look at
things.
And I always like to say that modern games have so much artistry put into them
that is largely wasted or lost on the players where you have the fire
extinguisher sitting in the corner that some artists lovingly crafted for a week
and you just glance at it, see the pixels and move on.
But in VR you wind up saying, it's like, oh, I'm in this room,
I'm looking at this. You read, you know, lean down.
Or even pick something up and turn it around and look at it. And you know,
and that's really great,
but the larger spaces have these hazards and it turns out that it's hard to
protect people from themselves in some cases because we started saying, well,
what if somebody's swinging their hand really hard? I am. You know, we don't,
we want them to be able to stop their hand and even if we show when the hand is
really close to it, they're not going to have time.
So we put in this predictive filter to say,
based on the velocity of how fast you're moving your hand,
maybe we'll start showing up the boundary a second earlier if we think you're
going to hit it in a second, we'll show the boundary now.
But then everybody says, oh, I don't want that flashing up.
It's distracting me and we need to put in parameters to turn it down.
It's a real balancing act.
There were a lot of developers just kind of go in and say, turn off Guardian,
I'll accept the risks for this. But I yes,
of course the lawyers are very concerned for this. We have a,
we have some duty of care to the people that are our customers. I,
there are some interesting youtube videos of people playing VR,
not setting things up right. In like running into walls and so on.
And even internally it's, I am, if you don't set it up right, if you,
uh, if you extend it further than you should,
there are people that have smacked their knuckles into a table or something and
kind of post the bloody knuckles picture from that.
But it's on you on how conservative you want to be with it.
It was interesting when I stepped outside of the, what is it called?
The Guardian. Yeah. Whatever it is a, the, the, the,
the matrix that shows up and you, you walk through,
then you see the regular world.
Like you step out of the virtual world and you're into the regular world,
but you're seeing it through this weird lens. Yeah. So it's I am,
it's black and white because it's using the same cameras.
Like on the quest there are four cameras that I am are pointed off in different
directions and they have two jobs to do. They,
they track where the headset is by looking at the world around it.
They find stable little pieces of the world and based on where they are as you
move around,
it can figure out where the headset is and then they also look at the
controllers and the controllers have little invisible ear LEDs on it. I am,
but it takes this black and white image of the world from the four different
views and it can pass through the real world. It's pretty low. Rez,
I doesn't have color,
but it's good enough for important things like finding where you put your
controllers and letting you Orient Yourself because depending on what you do in
VR,
if you spend a couple hours in an environment where you're turning around and
moving, it can be very shocking to people when they,
I sort of come out of it and they, they're in the opposite corner of the room.
They thought they should be either pointed in a different direction.
I having the ability to kind of bring the world into place,
especially in those cases where you're approaching the boundaries is a,
it's nice.
Is there anything that you guys have that can or maybe in the future can map out
uneven terrain?
Like say if you were at a park and there was a hill or in your backyard or
something like that. We have various sort of surfaces.
You have a sidewalk and then grass than a hill. Is there ever go, there's,
there's a few aspects to that you can set up really large.
I am guardian boundaries. We do have an upper limit on it. I,
but again some developers have disabled that to do even larger areas and one of
the coolest experiences that I had was at a convention last year and artists had
made a basically a VR sculpture that was really big.
It was like 50 feet long. I am,
you are inside this kind of aquarium looking thing in a workshop and we sketched
out this giant boundary and I walked around like I walked literally from room to
room in virtual reality. Again,
very few people have the space to set something like this up in their house,
but we were at a convention center and the ability to walk through a door in
virtual reality,
get down on my hands and knees and crawl through a crawl space into another
magical little area. That was really something,
I mean it's not clear how we can carry that over to other people,
but the idea of doing it outside I am.
There's a few technical issues with it where bright sunlight overpowers the
little tiny LEDs on the controllers.
So while it's possible to sort of stop down the exposure on the cameras for
tracking the headset, if it's reasonably bright,
you're not going to be able to resolve the controllers,
which breaks some things.
But people have found that if you get the right overcast day I am and you've got
the right environment,
you can go out to a like a tennis court or a or a big field or something,
stretch out a large boundary and explore some fairly sizable things now really
accurate determination of the world.
Facebook reality labs has done a lot of research for almost what is the absolute
limit of what we could possibly do with the sensors for building the most
accurate representation of the world and it's pretty damn good when you get to
the point where they could take off in a really cluttered room like this,
scan the world for all of this and they could make a real 3d representation so
you could then be good enough that I can go ahead and pick up individual things
here, but it's still a,
it's pretty expensive to do that both in terms of the needs,
some slightly different sensors they have to project more structured light out
into the world. It takes a lot more calculation to do it.
It's too much for this generation of products here,
but certainly that's something that we're looking at in the future where
eventually we want to not have that one step of drawing out the Guardian.
You just want it to be both.
I am sensible enough that it can tell what's going on in the environment and
sort of smart enough to tell what's a hazard because you want that magic of you
just put it on, it does everything and it just works. We're not there yet,
but that is sort of on the roadmap for where we want to go.
So you think there will be a time where the technology will allow you to maybe
possibly have several filter layers,
like you can see the whole world and it would be more of an augmented reality
toward sort of a situation or the whole world disappears and then it could be
virtual. Yeah. So there's, we have a lot of debates about,
I am both the useful things that you might do there and then some real technical
aspects where in terms of augmented reality,
this idea that we all buy into this future vision of a world where you've got
something that's the s you know the fields like sunglasses that you put on and
you can pull up all your information and maybe it clouds over into a virtual
experience. There are still,
I'm fundamentally unsolved problems in display technology to do the magic thing
that we would really like from all of that. So you step back to saying that,
well what you saw in quest when you saw the world through that,
obviously it's low Rez, it's low frame rate, it's not good,
but we could fix all of that. You could say let's go higher rez color,
high refresh rate and you could make a,
we'd call that a pass through rather than a see-through augmented reality system
and we could absolutely build that technology and we could make that pretty
good. But it comes down to what do we expect sort of the user story to be.
If you had something like that I would you be wearing this boxy thing out,
you know, out into the world, riding the bus with it, doing different things.
We have a little bit of a hard time seeing the kind of socially acceptable way
that you're running around going about your life with sort of the shoe box size
thing on your head. It's an open question where everybody agrees.
If it came down to sunglasses,
everybody in the world is going to want something like that.
If it gives them these magical abilities and it can turn into virtual reality or
augmented reality. It's an open question whether there's an in between layer.
If we get down to the point where it's something like swim goggles or very thin,
I'm sort of ski goggles,
something that's half or a quarter of the volume of what we've got here.
Would that be something that people would want to wear for long periods of the
day? I lean towards no, but we haven't built it so we don't know yet. I am.
And then the question of what you want to do with that in the augmented reality
world where people make these interesting little demos where, all right,
we've mapped the world in this incredible detail and now we can flood it with
water. We can do a simulation of all of this. Isn't this cool?
Or we can turn it into a,
we can reskin your world as Bilbo Baggins hobbit hole or something.
And I am skeptical of the broad utility of a lot of these things where like
today there's a ton of Ar apps that you can get on your cell phone.
You can hold your phone up and kind of look at things and interesting little
things happen. Well,
Pokemon go is an interesting thing where that actually has more of a point for
it. And the augmented reality side of it is very small,
but the things that actually augment onto the world,
I haven't seen anything that I, that I've found really compelling.
They're interesting technologies, but I think that the, I'm,
I'm still betting more on the fully immersive experiences where you take over
and this idea of bringing part of it into the world.
I'm a little more skeptical on, but I don't know how it's gonna play out.
Well that's the concept behind magic leap, right? Yeah. And magic leap was very,
very hyped up a couple of years ago,
but it hasn't really come to fruition yet in terms of like a consumer product
that people could, I mean,
remember the little girl and there was a ballerina that was dancing on her hand
and it was like, is this going to happen?
So the problem with magic leap was they had a lot of the augmented reality
videos. I,
you wind up with things that are synthetically created and they're not really
what the product does. And they oversell what they, the actual capabilities are.
And that's a slippery slope there where you want to sell your vision in some way
and you know, you're really,
you're very rarely showing exactly what the product does,
but they showed something that led people to believe it was much more than it
actually was. But even before magically,
Microsoft had been selling the Holo Lens for a few years and it's turned out
that they have some real wins in,
I've in some enterprise applications for training and for people like working on
jet engines and stuff where it's an expensive product and costs thousands of
dollars for these things, you're not going to spend that to get a,
it's got a fairly narrow field of view. It's not a great gaming experience.
They have a few things that you can do with that.
But if it's something that helps you do your job and you're a high paid
specialist for something, it's a tool. You know, it's something that, uh,
that has value there.
But that's the state that we are in with ar today where there are some devices
that are providing some legitimate value, but they are essentially,
they're like socket wrenches.
There are tool you get when you need to do a specific job where the world that
we want to be in is,
it's something you put on and it's essentially a part of you where I want
something where I roll out of bed instead of grabbing my normal see-through
glasses,
I grabbed my augmented reality glasses and then they do something useful for me
for 16 hours and that's where, you know, two hours is not enough.
We have a few of, uh,
there's a few companies that have made things that are sunglasses form factor
that can do some little things with a display but they run out of battery very
quickly.
But you want something that you can use all day long and if it becomes something
that is so automatic, like cell phones or augmentations of our power right now,
the fact that we can go look anything up a super quickly if you have that
ability and it doesn't even mean pulling your phone out of your pocket if you
can access information, I adjust by potentially even just thinking about it.
I mean there is work serious work going on about brain computer interfaces where
you could imagine having these glasses and even if it was all it did was say
zooming in, say it was just supervision.
If you had the ability to just think zoom and it would zoom in for something
that would be a product right there.
It could grow into this augment to the world and annotate everything and do all
of that other stuff later.
But I'm a believer that this a sense of giving you a new power,
giving you a new physical ability and either it needs to be ultra intuitive.
I mean maybe there is something where I'm just tapping your wrist or some super,
super fast low latency interaction. But ideal would be something like I,
you know, brain computer interface.
Maybe it's some eye tracking or even teeth clicking or something that you could
do.
But if it just became so natural that just like you think you turn your head to
go look at something,
if you just do this thing and you zoom in on it and you get more information,
that would be pretty magical. That sense of augmenting human capability.
Have you paid attention to the Ceylon Mosque neurolink thing?
So I actually went out to visit the neuron,
the link company I was like the week before they did their big public
announcement and I spent a whole day there kind of deep diving with a bunch of
their technical people and it is exciting stuff because it is,
you know, I,
I like to use the word bold for things like that where it's not just this
incremental advance where it's just taking something,
fixing a few of the flaws and going out.
It is visionary looking to the future where the potential upside of this,
about being able to make the whole automated electronic world,
something that is directly accessible on both input and output to your brain is
really remarkable. And I what they've done,
I mean there's a lot of people where you can say it's like,
well other companies might have these capabilities. I,
but clearly they are at the cutting edge. I've,
you could argue how far above or or behind other companies they might be,
but I think it's going to largely work to some degree here and they're going to
be working with people that are like seizure patients,
people that are in many cases profoundly disabled and they don't expect it's
going to work forever when they put it in there.
All these problems with the brain,
I kind of rejecting implants eventually and there are people who've done
experiments like this for quite a while. It starts off with just one neuron.
You stick in one sensor or one actuator and in the neurolink case,
now they've got tens of thousands that they can put in so much,
much higher fidelity even if it doesn't work forever and they're still working
out the different, uh, the coatings tactics, different installation procedures.
I,
somebody is going to go in there and be go from being profoundly disabled to
probably being able to play a video game. You know,
being able to sort of directly control things with your mind where you start off
being able to do maybe just very slowly driving a cursor and people have done
this again for years where you can slowly move a mouse cursor or something and
figure out a click thing.
But here when you have tens of thousands of neurons going in,
you could go from this very slow moving something to doing this deep analog
multi-dimensional,
like playing a symphony with your brain output potentially and then potentially
feeding information in in a way that we can't right now that you could have this
sort of tactile feel to it. Do you remember lawnmower man? Yeah.
Vaguely goes, yeah. I've talked to myself sometime.
I should go back and watch that because I literally have not watched that since
it came out when I was a teenager and the VR is laughable at this point and
everything, but it should be good for a chuckle. Well, it was a con,
I think it was a clunky movie,
but the idea was based on a Stephen King Book and the Stephen King Book where
there was a guy who was sort of slow and they did something to him and all of a
sudden he became some super genius, almost godlike character.
Like if this neurolink stuff does work and you can take a person with profound
disabilities and all of a sudden they become the smartest human beings on the
planet. That would be really weird.
So I know that was one of the pitches that Ellen was making early on that Elon
is very concerned about artificial intelligence and part of neurolink was this
pitch that, well,
maybe we can supercharge humans in a way that the AI won't run away so far or we
can at least interact with them on a more level playing field.
I am less, I am sanguine about that. I am, I am.
That seems a little bit more of a reach to me because I suspect that, okay,
even if you do put a million neurons in when we're making artificial general
intelligence is they're going to have billions and billions of these different
connections.
And I think that it might be many steps above what a human could be.
But if AI becomes possible and takes off,
and I am a believer in artificial general intelligence,
I think it's probably not as far off as many,
many people believe that it is likely to be able to accelerate and advanced
faster than even a neuro linked human would be able to.
And how far would you think we are from artificial general intelligence?
So by nature I'm an optimist. I am, you know, I tend to,
I do underestimate how long things take, but on the other hand, as a programmer,
I've usually been able to say, well,
maybe I missed my estimate by 50% while everybody else blew it by 100% or
something. I think that we will have,
we will potentially have unclear signs of AGI maybe as soon as a decade from
now. Wow. Now, lots of people disagree.
The majority of scientists working on it think it's like, oh,
it's going to be at least a few decades.
And you still have a few holdouts that say, oh, it can't happen at all.
But I'm a strict materialist. I think that, you know,
our minds are just our body and action and there's no reason why we can't wind
up simulating that in some way. I am.
So I don't think the question of how far out,
there's a lot of numbers that you can play.
Like the brain has something like 85 billion neurons in it and the room,
they have something like 10,000 connections between it and you can multiply
those out and compare them to what we have in computer memory and processing
time. And you can say that, yeah,
within 10 years those curves should have crossed.
But I would even go so far as to say most of those are probably not completely
necessary.
We know lots of biological systems like we understand the processing that goes
on a lot in the visual side and we don't need nearly as many computer
transistors as neurons that are used for processing some of those early layers.
So I suspect that even today some of the government supercomputers that the
biggest, the top 500 lists that they have,
those are remarkably,
I probably useful for doing intel artificial intelligence work where for a long
time, for decades,
I thought that was sort of just I am national chess thumping the top 500
computers because so many of them they relied on replacing what used to be the
old big iron cray vector super computers and they really weren't very easy to
program. Most programs people want to use,
you can't run it on a supercomputer and just be a lot faster.
One of the shocking things most people don't really appreciate is the fastest
way to do most single threaded applications is an overclocked gaming computer.
Today,
you can't go spend $1 million and buy a computer that will do many tasks faster
than what you can just run on a gaming computer and this is not at all the way
things were for decades where for a long time you would go spend your millions
of dollars on a cray supercomputer and all of your code would run faster than
anything you can get. But it turned out that the a,
the processors that you wind up using in high end gaming systems are in many
cases the fastest or in all cases at least close to us fast were certain serial
applications. So the only thing else you can do is pile lots more of them.
And these big computers are football field sized systems that are just racks and
racks of GPU and CPU [inaudible] and nowadays for a long time I'd be like,
well what would you, I would think,
how could I make a faster quakemap build or something on one of those because we
would sometimes have hours and hours spent processing this and I am,
at one point we had a computer that was almost in the top 500 I added software
just for making our maps. I, but I looked at a lot of these supercomputers.
I'm like, oh, these are terrible. Not very useful for what we want. I am.
But now as I look at AI work, and I think that,
well if you're just doing a whole bunch of these,
I kind of general matrix multiplies that computer right there.
There's probably pretty good.
So I would suspect that you could do something if we had the right algorithms,
the right training schedule, and the right time to run through it,
that it's probably possible on some systems today and it'll just still take many
years for the right algorithms to wind up being developed.
The right training regimens to be run and faster, cheaper hardware to wind it,
making it more economical to run all the experiments because in so many cases
the trick is not that the minimum requirements exist,
but that a thousand people have thrown themselves at the wall of a problem.
Most of them have bounced off and failed, but eventually somebody gets through.
Now what about quantum computing?
Is that something that could potentially break the bottleneck that we have with
Moore's law? So I don't,
I am not an expert on quantum computing and I think that I,
as many times I beat myself up about it where there's some simulators online
where you can go and work on it and I should work through the exercises of doing
the basic factoring algorithms on quantum computing.
But I know my read on it right now is that it's probably not directly useful for
most of the artificial intelligence tasks.
The big things that people worry about that are for things like breaking
cryptography,
breaking the different hashing and encryption methods that it's possible that in
many ways that's almost a terrible technology because it's a technology that
doesn't solve so many of the problems that you'd like it to solve.
And it does solve one of the problems you kind of wish nobody was able to solve.
I am so by breaking all of the encryption, you know,
like if somebody winds up I with a quantum computer that they achieve quantum
supremacy and it runs past all of our traditional computers and all of a sudden
they can break all of the, all of the secure socket layer stuff,
break everybody's signatures, impersonate any public key sign stuff.
There's no upside to this.
That's all downside and all bad things that are going to come from that while
it's not going to make your video and coding go any faster and it's probably not
going to help artificial intelligence in many ways.
So I haven't found a whole lot to get me really excited about quantum computing.
It may just be that.
And with all of these cases why I beat myself up about not learning more about
it because in most cases when presented with some capability,
there's some way to figure out how to apply it usefully to the things that you
really want. In fact,
I consider that almost the essence of engineering engineering
is figuring out how to do what you want with what you've actually got and if
somebody gives, anytime somebody gives me new hardware,
usually I can figure out some useful way to do things that I want with it,
even if it's not immediately obvious and maybe quantum computing plays out that
way, but I'm,
it is still definitely the domain of big labs with cryogenic cooling and all
that stuff, so it just hasn't been at the top of my radar.
Now when we talk about technology and you talk about the exponential increase in
the powers of technology,
is it possible that we could come to a point in time somewhere in the future
where there's no way to encrypt anything where it's not possible to hide things
where we won't be able to do banking online?
We won't be able to have digital currency because virtually everyone will have
access to all the information cause essentially digital currency or anything
that's encrypted. It's just information, right? It's just ones and zeroes.
Is it possible that technology will reach a point in time where borders and
boundaries are impossible? So I,
one thing that a lot of people don't appreciate about cryptography is there's a
really straightforward way to make completely unbreakable cryptography and
that's what's called a one time pad where if you essentially have, I'm,
you know, a long, you know, a very long set of data and it's private,
as long as nobody else has it, you can encrypt anything with it.
And if it was generated randomly, properly, uh,
you always have to worry about flaws in your random number generation or your
random number source. But a properly generated one time pad is unbreakable.
Now the problem is it's finite.
So you have a fixed amount of it and all of the really serious spy craft would
use something like that where you've got a onetime pad,
you can send a message through it.
In the old days when you were manually doing it,
you might only have a book with a certain number of pages and once it's over
it's gone and you can't get more without returning to base.
But this is always a possibility. And as we've seen,
storage density's increased so much.
The fact that you can get a little micro sim card that's holding hundreds of
gigabytes now, which is pretty remarkable.
You could imagine a world like if we did have this quantum apocalypse where all
of these short 512, 1024 bit keys, whatever,
all of those just get smashed irrevocably eye. You could imagine a world where,
I mean heck, maybe people start implanting the one time pad inside people.
So whatever, you know, whatever you need to encrypt that's coming from you.
Has this, uh, you know, this clear unbreakable key that you're working with.
Do you think that we're going to have things implanted in our bodies soon that
allow you to interface with computers or technology or wireless Internet?
I think that it's possible that it will. I am. It would,
we have people that want to do that right now. In fact, that wasn't,
she planted a Tesla chip in her arm so that she could just get close to her car
and the door would open. So in fact, one of the things that,
talking with the neuro link people,
the idea that of course right now you start off, you say you take somebody
profoundly disabled and you put them in a laboratory and you try to train them
how to use this. But we were all saying like, well,
what you really need is a programmer to get this interface,
you need to be able to let a programmer actually program themselves on their
interface and you will make a hundred times more progress than this, you know,
previously disabled person coming into the lab for a couple hours a day.
And it was funny the conversation there where one of their guys was like, yeah,
we'll give them the basic rule so they don't stroke themselves out. I'm like,
okay, yeah, that's kind of important. Talk about health and safety rules there.
But I, yeah,
if you start getting a programmer in there that starts running this like,
all right, instead of just going through these basic exercises,
they run everybody through,
you really understand exactly what you're doing and you change it.
You write the code as you're experiencing it and there are probably people
volunteering that are ready to go do that. To have something like that.
I read an article sometime after that about one of the early uh,
neurosurgeons that did implant himself with some electrodes.
He had to go to one of these eye fringe countries that didn't have any ethical
guidelines around the medical practices or whatever.
What everybody paid a neurosurgeon in one of those countries to implant an
electrode into his head and even had some complications afterwards and was like,
no, there's a dedicated researcher. Although interestingly there,
there's the whole history of a lot of medical science where you would get people
that would wind up having the conviction to do the experiments on themselves and
you know, you've got to respect that where it's one thing to, you know,
make a grant proposal to set up a study to do all of this and it's another one
to say, damn it, I am so confident in this.
I'm going to have someone cut a hole in my skull and implant this in me so we
can learn the lessons. What was his complications? Do you remember? He had some,
I have some problems with speech afterwards. He had to learn how to do that.
Like half of his face had a little bit of a sag to it from the going get in
there. So yes,
it was life affecting changes as a result of going with that. And this wasn't,
I don't off hand I but it w this was,
it was a wired article I think from a number of years back,
but this was like a single electrode.
It was just doing very one bit or one analog value computation and he had a
little transponder kind of put in under the skin of his skull,
had a big lump on his head with that while interesting. Again,
the the neural link stuff,
all modern high tech where you kind of power it with RF through the skull and
it's got a little plug and I,
one of the first one you on first kind of approached me about,
I kind of talking with them about that. The idea and the thinking,
which was kind of insightful,
was this idea that the io levels that they were doing on the neuro link or they
were planning on doing with that was fairly close to what we do on virtual
reality where, okay,
we've got theoretically maybe up to a million inputs here and a million outputs
and I can run those numbers and say,
well that's kind of like the cameras that we're taking in and the display that
we're, we're putting out. And I made the point that, well,
you probably could run that off of like a Qualcomm chip that we've got in here.
You'd set it all up as like turn them into what are called MIPI lanes for the
input and output. Make the inputs look like a camera on,
make the outputs look like a display screen,
and you could then run software on something like what we use here to drive your
brain.
Like the programmer could then kind of start running some of those experiments
with it. Well,
it's so fascinating being on the outside watching all this stuff come to
fruition because I remember when virtual reality was sort of,
it was something that was tossed around in the 80s and we talked about the
future and that was one of the things that people were really concerned about or
looking forward to in the future was virtual reality,
but the technology really wasn't there. Yeah, so I have stories from,
in the early days I did software every game from Wolfen Stein, doom and quake.
We had at least one VR entrepreneur that wanted to work with us.
I because finally here was content because they were like,
everybody had this vision of VR.
Like it's this hazy vision of the future where cool stuff happens when you put
the helmet on. But they didn't have this concrete eye instantiation of like,
well what do you actually do? And then people saw the three d games is like, oh,
that's what you want to do inside the virtual reality helmet.
So they would come up and they'd want to basically work with us licensed the
technology and every time I looked at these and like, oh,
this is just isn't going to work out.
I in many cases they were people that were very,
they were high on enthusiasm but a little low on the raw technical necessities
to make something like this happen. Because really it was too early.
I mean there were systems that if you had unlimited money,
you could get a big SGI, refrigerator sized infinite reality system, uh,
that could render images. That could be interesting.
But people talk about the current resolution limits here are like the original,
the original dkone kind of the views for their,
those headsets back then they were the resolution of,
remember the original Pixel doom.
I like three 20 by two 40 sort of resolutions there,
but wrapped around your head, somebody called them football sized pixels,
you know, like you've got this big blurry blob off to the side.
So it was never going to happen in those early days.
So we always made the point of saying, well, okay,
we'll license this stuff to you. But uh, you know,
I wouldn't put a dime of my investment money into something like that because I
just thought it was too early.
And then here we are a couple of decades later and the future has arrived.
It seems like it was about a decade ago that people started really taking it
seriously again, we, where the technology had caught up to the vision. So it's,
I, I think that,
I think we can date all of it to the demo that I gave at [inaudible] I am,
which had the doom three as the kind of running there because it was amazing
talking to people.
I got into it several months before that and I had this thought, okay,
I had just finished finished rage. Uh,
the last game that I had worked on there and I was like, all right,
between each project I would do research,
I would take a time to go ahead and explore some new technology,
whether it was in the game rendering or something related to it. And I thought,
well, virtual reality back in, I remember dealing with that in the 90s,
it's been 20 years surely they've sorted this out by now, you know,
it was a matter of the technology was terrible back then,
but here we are closing in on a million times faster processors.
Surely somebody just sorted this out and I was shocked when I went and I looked
through, I surveyed everything and it really wasn't,
there was a cottage industry of people that would serve basically department of
defense contracts that would make these very expensive systems that were,
you know, tens to in some cases like $150,000 for some of these big things.
And they weren't even very good. It was,
it was offensive to me as an engineer where I look at the capabilities of what's
possible. You know, I, I say this is our display, this is our processing,
these are our sensors. What is the limit?
I always talk about the speed of light calculations.
Like if everything was perfect, how good could it be?
And I could look at what we had and say,
it could be a whole hell of a lot better than what we have here,
what people are shipping and that are charging these very high prices for it.
And so that was when I started cobbling things together myself. Uh, you know,
and that's what led to working with, uh, you know,
Palmer at the start of Oculus and led to where we are today. What year was that?
So 2011 in the first work. Think so recent. Yeah, that's crazy.
So, you know, less than a decade. And um,
now we have it down to a one wearable headset that sits on your head.
My,
my friend Dunkin's first unit was connected to a computer and you had cables
that you would trip over. And I think there was a backpack involved as well.
So there is still some reason to want to use the computer where one of the
points that I like to make is that I, while cell phone technology,
which is definitely what these stand-alones run on is astounding and how much
power we've gotten out of these. But your high end gaming PC rig I,
it's a difference of it's 50 times more powerful. It is just way, way,
way more powerful.
And if you just want to make something happen quickly and easily,
it's easy on the PC where you have to sweat pretty hard to make some intense
things happen on the cellular systems. I am.
And one of the interesting things is I make the point to people that we are so
used to computers just getting faster and faster and they have for, you know,
for decades and decades our entire life basically.
But we are approaching the end of that.
People talk about the end of Moore's law like you mentioned.
And I've had to tell people that while we've still got a lot more power to come,
the next decade still going to be good.
It is very likely barring some magical new technology,
which fingers crossed maybe we get,
but you will probably never get the cell phone technology.
I to the point that a modern gaming PC is,
which on the one hand sounds like obviously that's a different thing,
but on the other hand,
if you've been here through this million x increase in performance,
it's a little bit of a Downer to think that no,
we just can't wait another 10 years and we'll have everything we could do there
available in the systems.
So it does mean a little bit of a cultural change to to start thinking more
about performance rather than just say throw everything at it. And then,
and that used to be what I did in the early days. It did.
We would make these bleeding edge things where only a few people at the start
had good enough computers or people would get it and they were running it.
A low frame rate.
It made them want to go upgrade their computer and wanted to go get the latest
thing or buy a GPU. I, you know, do the thing to make the game better.
But we are,
we are approaching the limits of what's going to be happening with that.
I am so you have to be better. You know,
you have to be a more conscientious developer. You have to,
I start paying attention to all of the different aspects of performance that on
the PC you can still largely gloss over. Uh, and I like that. I mean,
as an old school optimizer where I always appreciated the challenge.
That's why my entire time at Oculus I've been focused on these mobile systems
where in many ways it's easier to do spectacular things on the PC.
But mobile is super important and it's more of a challenge. You know,
it winds up fitting a little bit better for me,
but there are generations of game developers, especially now that have been,
I have grown up making PC titles where it's easy and they have to educate
themselves quite a bit now to go ahead and make the step down to something with
less than a 10th or you know, less than a 50th in some cases of the raw power.
When you're talking about the end of Moore's law,
what is the limitation that we're facing technologically?
Like why is it going to, why are there,
why is there going to be a point where they can't get any more powerful?
So the way the chips work is you have these, I am, you know,
they wind up sketching out basically wires onto the silicon chips and they have
gotten so small that the wire that the current is flowing through is a handful
of atoms wide, which is just astounding if you think about it, you know,
these are these fundamental elements of matter and the wire is this small
integer number of atoms wide. Now in theory, you can keep going down and say,
well, maybe we can make a one atom wide electrical path,
but you wind up running into eventually all of these quantum effects where if
you make a very narrow wire and you pack them very close together,
you have two wires there and electron won't necessarily stay on that one wire of
conductor that you want it to be on.
Because of the way I quantum mechanics work, it is going to wind up jumping.
They call it quantum tunneling.
There is a percentage chance and quantum is all about randomness like that,
but an electron flowing here,
there's going to be this chance that it just teleports essentially to a nearby
wire.
It takes this discrete quantum jump to another wire and this is reality.
It's shocking. It's not intuitive.
People have a hard time kind of grasping a lot of this,
but quantum tunneling is a real thing and we are bumping into quantum limits.
They can still shrink more than we are right now where we're down at seven
nanometers in the latest us stuff.
Although there's all sorts of issues with marketing,
speak about exactly how they measure it,
but they're still getting smaller and there's still room to get smaller still.
But the end is in sight. It can't go too much.
And one of the things that becomes an issue is just the economics of it.
Each generation has gotten more and more expensive. If you went back,
I am 30 years, there were a whole bunch of semiconductor places that could fab.
I'm, you know, different chips.
You could go ahead and have a design and you could shop it out to a whole bunch
of different places. Find the one that worked best for you.
But it's come down to the point now where it costs billions of dollars to make a
new fab.
And at the high end process is you're left with just DSMC Samsung and Intel.
I'm very few companies, you know,
AMD held on for a while until they spun theirs out and it's IX.
It's so expensive and it,
that's one of the challenges where they will have full confidence that we'll see
a couple more node shrinks. I am still, it'll still make chips cheaper. Uh,
somewhat faster, more cores on them,
but it is going to be at an end of the line.
But I hold out hope for potential other things,
you know there are directions that, you know,
maybe you have your carbon nanotube wires or you're starting able to be able to
do some things with photonic processing in different ways.
There are possible outs for it,
but I don't know that any of them are assure enough thing to really be counting
on at this point.
It's so hard for a dummy like me to wrap my head around that.
But when you're talking about these wires, so if these wires,
it's size dependent, when they get too small,
then this quantum tunneling becomes completely unpredictable.
Is that what it is? So I,
if you draw out like a probability density function of like you've got a
particle and you like to think about particles as being like this hard little
billiard ball that's sitting here in this specific place, that's sort of the,
you know,
the vision that you used to see in grade school textbooks about here's an Adam,
you've got these billiard balls in the middle of surrounded by the electrons
moving around. But in actuality they're really these eye,
these distribution functions, they, it sounds so weird,
but they have a chance at being in all of these different places and this is not
a curve that goes to zero.
There is a non zero chance that a given Adam, you know,
could wind up being a macroscopic distance away,
but there is a real chance that it could wind up being a few atoms away. So the,
uh, you know, the electron moving around at the edge of this wire,
if it just says, well,
I've got some chance of being over here and if you've got billions of these are
quadrillions probably of electrons moving around in this,
even if it's a small chance.
Eventually it's going to jump over there and enough of them jump over and all of
a sudden you've got a wrong bit and you've got a mistake.
So we start fighting all of that by doing error correcting codes and doing ways
that there's this whole set of technology about how you work with unreliable
systems, which starts getting starts.
It should start making you feel a little bit uneasy that, okay,
we're going to have this error rate, but we're going to buy this carefully.
Crafted codes allow ourselves to constantly be failing,
constantly having errors and still getting the right answer in a statistical
enough case.
Now there's a lot of things like the way your cell phone works with the way the
radio signal is interpreted.
There's a lot of things that do work in this sort of probabilistic way,
but when people are used to computers as being accurate thing
where you always get the right answer,
that sense of moving to something that has a larger chance or is a more
probabilistic computation still feels a little bit sketchy in some ways.
Now, do you keep tabs on latest cellular technology as well? I mean,
I know you're a coder and you code for games,
but do you keep tabs on all the various incremental increases in cellular
technology?
And so it's interesting right now where we have a lot of 5g companies that I am,
that's what they've sort of got a problem of how to sell 5g where fundamentally
it's just a bigger pipe to,
to everyone's computers and it should be this relatively boring thing,
but they need to await to kind of make it sexy in some way.
And several of them want VR to be that way where, you know,
how can we use VR in a way that I,
that leverages the 5g I experience and it's not a spectacular fit because I have
many of the things like, you know, say beat Saber that uses no data transfer.
It's like all it does is check you're spot on the leaderboard after you're done.
5G does nothing at all for that.
But there are some things that you can look at with the immersive media like
playing three 60 3d videos where it's like, okay,
it would be nice to have more bandwidth here,
but it's not that it's made possible by 5g.
It's just 5g will give more people a reliable 20 megabit bandwidth or something
than they have on the current systems.
It's a tough marketing problem for them where changing your cellular
infrastructure,
each one where you have to go into tens of thousands of specific dollar base
stations and pull out the racks and replace them. It's very,
very capital intensive and they would like to be able to have some cool
marketing ploy to make people, you know,
think this is great switch carriers over to this where the bottom line is it
gives you more bandwidth and perhaps more importantly it does cut the latency
more.
It's possible that things like cloud gaming over five g networks may be more of
a thing. Uh,
the idea of actually playing games instead of installing them locally,
they run in data centers and they can just go ahead and wirelessly get to you
with low enough latency to so that in many cases you wouldn't be able to notice.
When you're watching this from the outside and you're seeing all this technology
develop,
are you concerned at all when you see how addicted people are to their phones?
Because this, like your games are very addictive in the best ways, right?
Quick is super addictive. It's really fun.
It's great to play and that's why it's addictive because you just won't get that
charge, that rush to get back in there.
But the odd thing to me about cell phone addiction is there's not much thrill.
It's a weird addiction where you're just constantly checking and nothing's
coming back. Like people are just constantly checking their email and their,
their Twitter messages, their dms and youtube videos.
But there's not a lot coming back at you. I'm,
I'm concerned.
I see this thing where you'll go to a place and you'll see 80% of the people
just looking at their phones and not interacting with people.
Do you ever like look at that and go, where's this going?
So I do think about this in a way that,
because this is one of these things where I recognize it in some other people
where I think I probably do interact with things a little bit differently and I
am sometimes conscious of the fact that most people don't think about things the
way I do. And it's clear that yes,
a lot of people just ay they get rage out of Twitter. And I that I can see it.
Some people, it's probably bad for them doing some of these social media things.
But I mean I, I get inspiration out of Twitter. I mean my feet,
I'm going through, I'm seeing brilliant scientists, new research developments,
wonderful art from people, hard workers, developing products.
And I just look at this as like,
this is this amazing set of human beings that are building the future and I've
got this window into their mind and it winds up being a very positive thing for
me. But I do see the people that just wind up having eye that it is a negative
aspect for them. And I don't know what to do about that because I mean,
talking about people issues are obviously not my strong suit.
I'm the nuts and bolts or bits and bites technology person and social
challenges. I mean, that's one of the things that probably over, you know,
over decades.
I've just come to be more at peace with the fact that I probably do think a bit
differently than most people. I don't expect them to, you know,
to think necessarily like I do.
And in many ways that keeps me from being upset at a lot of people and just say,
well, people are different.
They're not going to process these things the same way that I do. Uh, but yeah,
I can see it as potentially a problem.
But I do think also there's this ability for people to,
people always want to say it's okay, put down your phone.
Why aren't you living in the real world?
And there's another aspect of that where for many people,
the world that you get in the virtual worlds,
whether it's on your phone or all the way to VR,
the whole reason you do that should be because it's better than the world that
you're choosing to step away from. And again,
it's harder for many people that are in an elite thought leader position.
If your life is awesome in every way that yeah,
you don't need that much from the virtual world,
whether it's on a cell phone or virtual reality. I mean if you've been,
you know, court side, backstage pit lane, whatever,
if you've done all of these things in real life,
the VR version of it is not going to be that compelling.
And if you saw people you know, fixated on all of that,
you'd probably think those people are not living in reality.
They should just be living in reality. But for so many people,
you know what they get the people on the other side of the phone that they're
interacting with that's red. That's where they'd rather be. You know,
the fact that people can find their tribe out of the billions of people in the
world, even if they live in some podunk town in the Midwest.
I think that's a really wonderful thing. And so while yes,
there is a negative tail on one side from it, I am,
I think that this connecting everyone is largely a good thing on net.
There are downsides.
Maybe there should be things we should be doing to mitigate the downsides,
but I think this connection of humanity is on that a positive thing
tend to agree with you that it is a positive thing. I think philosophically,
I think the way we understand each other, the way we communicate,
it's very radically different than our grandparents and all of it seems to be
moving in a place where we understand each other better.
And you're going to have your side effects like Twitter rage and,
and social media bias. And you know, these, uh,
confirmation bias groups where people just do sit in these echo chambers and
reiterate the same ideas over and over again in each other.
And you're also going to get people that are understanding cultures,
understanding each other, understanding psychology,
understanding the way the mind works and getting access to information at a rate
that's unprecedented in terms of the knowledge that you can get. Like just,
just being able to Google things.
Yeah. And it's, you know, and nobody, you know,
nobody can actually give them credit for it.
And like Mark Zuckerberg and the Facebook leadership,
they talk about the mission is to connect the world. And you know,
of course it's like, oh, okay,
of course the Facebook CEO is going to be mounting these things. But like,
I really legitimately do think that the Facebook leadership is doing this
because they think that's a positive thing. And I agree with them now.
I'm not a very social person. I'm an introvert.
I'm a hermit mode sort of person. So much of the time.
But I think that this is again a good thing that connecting more people,
giving them the opportunity to find people that they wouldn't otherwise be
interacting with people they wouldn't even have known existed in many cases.
I think we'll come out of this, you know,
looking back decades in the future there will have been all the tragic things
that happened with social media, but on net it's going to be good.
Now when you say you're a hermit, I mean th does that,
that sort of really lends itself to coding, right?
Because coding is an exorbitant amount of time just staring at a screen.
How much time do you think per day, like when you're in full code mode,
you spend, like if you're developing something,
how much time do you spend just staring at a screen? So
this is an interesting thing where at least once a year I get pulled into some
debate about overwork and bad working conditions and things where some people,
you know, the way I am,
people always wind up extrapolating sort of unacceptably where people think,
oh I worked 18 hour days or something. And I have to say, no,
I never worked 18 hour days because I know my productivity falls off a cliff
after 13 hours. I'm, you know,
that's about the longest that I can do any effective kind of computer work.
And the key to even being able to get an effective 13 hours is having multiple
tasks that you can switch between rather than just kind of sitting heads down,
grinding, beating your head against one specific topic. But I'm, you know,
I've been for most of my career now,
I like working a 60 hour work week. I like being productive. I, you know,
nowadays I have a, I have family and kids and I don't,
I usually that target by a bit now, but I,
if I ever don't hit 50 hours a week, I feel I'm being a slacker. I am.
I like building things. I like creating things and making forward progress.
This sense of in some small way I'm helping build the future. Um, you know,
I'm proud of the work that I do now in a big company like Oculus or in Facebook
is now I'm,
I probably only get to spend about 50% of my time actually programming.
The other half is being in meetings, trying to convince people about things,
pushing on strategy, doing all that type of stuff.
I don't actually manage anyone. I'd be a poor manager, uh,
at best I can lead by example and provide some kind of inspiration to follow
behind.
But I've never been good at trying to figure out how to get the best out of
individual people I am. But I do love, I, you know,
I love taking a retreat where I'll work out with a,
with my wife and family and say, okay,
I'm going to spend a week or something and I'm just going to be by myself and
I'm going to do nothing but programming. I'm,
I've got to largely cut myself off from the Internet. I am,
I used to do this by literally flying to another state. Uh, I,
my wife would set up some,
I like fly me to Florida or something and just get off and go to a hotel near
the airport.
So I'm not around anybody or anything that I would distract myself with. Uh,
you know, lately I w you know, I would wind up doing it more locally,
but that's still something that I've like, I would worry as I got older I,
or am doing more of this, I'm involved with strategy and management. Well am I,
I can I not do that as well as I used to.
But in the last couple of years I would go and take off and it's like I quickly
slip back into that where after a day of adjustment, then I'm back in.
It's like, all right,
here's my 13 hours in the day and here I am plowing through a bunch of things.
So you would just go by yourself and you wouldn't get weirded out by that.
You don't get lonely. Like, I like to think that I, you know,
sometimes I want to pull on that thread a little bit and say, well,
how would I do in a Snowden cabin someplace? I, you know,
would I get cabin fever or something? I have, and I'm pretty confident that,
I mean, a week's just not that big of, not that long of a time. I mean,
who knows if it was a month or longer than that. I'm not sure.
I've never run that experiment, but I, you know,
a week of doing that and then coming back and seeing my, uh, my family,
that's pretty great. I did that just,
I'm a little over a month ago for a,
for this year and I got to really kind of deep dive doing a bunch of, um,
artificial intelligence related work stuff that I was poking at. I am,
and that's, it really makes me smile. That sense of like, okay, I can dive in.
And the sense of learning new things, not just necessarily grinding on projects.
I mean, it's great to just be productive and say, wow,
I just crossed off these 10 things off the to do list.
But diving into newer fields that I'm not an expert on and learning what all the
other brilliant people in the world have been kind of caught a and getting the
Aha moments of going through that. Uh, yeah. It's amazing.
There's so many things to work on. Well, it's interesting because you're,
you're so pragmatic about your time and you have a,
a realistic understanding of your own physical limitations as well as what you
actually enjoy doing. You know, you,
that you actually enjoy diving into this work and getting this done. I mean,
so many people are tortured by their work. They do it,
but they don't like it that it's just something they have to do.
So it's very refreshing seeing someone who,
even though you have this really unusual job and you have this really unusual
task that you're trying to,
it's essentially designed for you or you're designed for it. Yeah.
And there are clear decisions that you make where the majority of technical
people at some point decide to make the pivot into some kind of management
level,
whether it's being a startup CEO or I just taking a VP position somewhere and,
and managing other people. And there's good reasons for that.
I mean now and argument that I would have with myself about how I had seen kind
of the transition from these very low level programming tools,
writing and assembly language to writing in higher level languages to using
application frameworks. And at some level you say,
well the next level of productivity enhancing program development is to work
with people. You know, you instead of writing the code yourself,
you find the team and you tell them what to work on.
I and that's the way most of the world runs.
That type of kind of groups and teams and hierarchies,
the work that makes the world go round, but it's not what I want to do,
you know? I don't want to be the one doing that.
And in many ways that's selfish where at some point if I said,
if I'm all about the project,
if I'm all about saying that I want to change the world in this way by bringing,
bringing this product into existence,
I should just suck it up and learn how to manage people and make that happen.
But it is selfishness that keeps me saying, it's like, no,
I dearly loved building the things myself. I don't want to step away from that,
even if it would be more effective. And I know that even if you go and do that,
so you, I could be maybe super effective for a couple of years at that,
but then my skills,
atrophy and the world moves on and I'm no longer at the cutting edge of those
different things.
And eventually I'm giving bad advice to the people that I'm managing or at least
not current and optimal advice. So I, I'm at peace with that.
I do sometimes look at, you know, other people were like, I think,
uh,
I think mark Zuckerberg made a very conscious decision that he's going to learn
to be a top notch CEO. I know he was a programmer,
but he decided to largely step away from that and says he's going to learn how
to manage a company. Well. I, you know, in many ways while Ilan still keeps his,
uh, his hands dirty and engineering to some degree,
most of what he does is make his way empire of companies, you know, run.
And that's a lot of work. And I think that, I mean,
I think he misses it to some degree. I, I had one time, I'm talking with him,
he had a little bit of a kind of a wistful thought about I talking about the
early days of programming things and I am willing to, I'm willing to,
to make that trade where I would rather continue to do the things that I dearly
love. And
maybe that keeps me from going to the next level. Maybe, you know,
maybe it prevents me from becoming a billionaire and I'm okay with that. I am,
but you know, maybe I do come across then, you know,
some next great thing that can productize in some way like that. Well,
it seems like you have to have a very specific personality to do that and you
have that personality. For me on the outside,
when I looked at people making games, like I've looked at,
I've been a fan of games for a long time and one of the things that's fascinated
me is this, this when a game starts building,
when it starts, when the process of creating a game starts,
there's this insane amount of work that has to get done in a relatively short
period of time and I get anxiety thinking about other people making games and I
don't even make games like there's been a few like Duke Nukem right for like it
was vaporware for the longest time. People are like,
when is this going to come out? Or Dika Tana was one of them.
I mean there was an, it was a very hyped up game. Everybody was super excited.
It took a long time for it to actually come to development is actually a pretty
fun game when it came out.
But I would get anxiety thinking about this like my God,
how much work is involved in these things? They can games is really,
really hard.
And this is kind of an interesting thing seeing the kind of the culture at
Facebook where you've got the, the big tech titans with the Facebook, Google,
apple, Microsoft, all that. And I,
you get a lot of people that roll right into that out of college.
And some of the people that have been in some of the other industries,
they do look at it and it's like, oh everybody is,
they have it so good at these big tech companies where they really are.
Everybody is taken care of incredibly well.
I they get all the different perks and I am, you know,
and then you look at that, the game industry where it doesn't pay as well.
I am they,
there's less job security and they work a lot harder.
But they have, and it's kind of a,
there is the problem of the fact that when you have an industry,
and this has been the way for artists forever and artists and musicians where if
you've got something that people are passionate about and want to be involved at
and I am supply and demand works there works its way and you wind up in a
situation where yeah, they don't have to be paid as much.
But the other side of that is it allows products that otherwise couldn't exist
to exist by people working at that level.
I in a way that maybe couldn't be sustained in other industries.
There are probably many of the greatest things that were ever made in gaming
were only possible by people throwing themselves at that level at it.
And there's some serious debate about it.
Some people despise that about the industry that you know,
nobody should work that hard. And there are people that you know,
that think there literally should be laws against that should prevent people
from working that hard.
And I always have to argue against that where there is a,
you know there is a power to obsession and like being able to absolutely obsess
over something and throw your, your life's work, you know,
instead of work life balance,
it's your life's work and everybody will point back. It's like,
well yeah that worked great for you. You, oh you were a founder of a company.
You are in a position where you got to make your own decisions.
But is that okay to say for the 19 year olds out of a game Dev program that's
being overworked for it and I have to always be aware that my view into the
industry is very colored by obviously my experiences.
I never actually worked inside of one of the big ea or Activision.
I am studios and it's possible that they have some valid criticisms,
but I still come down on I, I think it's,
I think it's great when people throw themselves at it beyond the point of what
even other people think is reasonable. They have free will.
They've chosen to do that.
And if that's what they think is going to help them get close to their goals,
I am, you know, I'm not going to try to make that impossible for them.
I think what people are concerned about those a accompany forcing an employer or
employee rather to work massive hours and that well, hey,
I want to work in video games and I'm very passionate about working video games
but I want to live, I want to be able to work eight hours a day,
which just seems to be a reasonable amount and then go on about with my life.
But you can't really do that if you're in a game development Kenya.
So again, I, my experience isn't the experience of everyone else, but we had,
I am so like Michael Abrash who is my right hand in the quake days. I am,
you know, he came from, he came from Microsoft,
I and he had a family.
I had a wife and daughter and he would work a reasonably normal schedule most of
the time. But he was awesome. So of course we were happy to have him.
It's not like anybody was brow beating Michael. It's like, Oh, you know,
why aren't you staying past midnight with us here?
Everybody was aware of his contribution and value. Now it,
that may not be the case in some other companies today,
but I suspect that if somebody,
if all of a sudden a person's peers know that they're doing spectacular work and
they say, I'm out of here at 5:00 AM, if they're actually doing valuable work,
I don't find the companies,
I don't find it that credible that the companies are going to get rid of people
doing great work. Uh, just because they're not spending 60 hours a week there.
But do they give you a requirement?
Like you are required to work 12 hours a day? Is that, is that reasonable?
Does that happen? So, no, I've never, again, I'm not involved in the, you know,
the HR departments of all of these companies,
but the ones that I have been familiar with or that I've known people doing that
largely, they come back and say, these people are choosing to do this.
And the rejoinder is it's like, oh,
it's a toxic culture that makes people want to choose to do that.
But I definitely don't buy into that sort of social engineering level of things.
It's like if they're doing it, they agree that they'll wave the flag and say,
I am doing this because I care so much about this. I am. Yeah,
I don't, I don't think that's a problem. Now,
when you look at the future of games, and you know,
we were talking about a first person
shooters and we're talking about oculus.
Do you envision a time where there'll be something where you maybe have a
unidirectional treadmill or something along those lines and you'll have a
standalone unit in your home with some sort of a gun? Well,
that's very accurate,
where you can actually reload it and you can get physical exercise while you're
running around in this virtual quake type environment.
So yeah, the ready player one vision,
that's a real thing that omnidirectional treadmill.
But you come into all of these used one, you know,
I actually haven't played on one of those.
I've played at somebody who's early prototype of I have one but I haven't seen
the very latest stages of things, but that's another one of those things.
I wouldn't put money into that because the joy of VR is the fact that it's like
this little thing.
You just pick it up and carry it around as soon as you're building material
things around it.
You've kind of defeated some of the purpose of VR and I think there's this niche
for things like location based entertainment where you go and do things like the
void where you have the physical gun.
You know you pick up the storm trooper gun, you go through a physical door,
but I don't think that's mass market. I am, but it is a real problem.
The idea of locomotion and how you move around in VR without getting sick and
the omnidirectional treadmill does sort of allow you to run in the different
directions. But in terms of getting, I am getting exercise from it again,
I play,
I play beat Saber pretty regularly and I wind up drenched in sweat afterwards.
I after a long session with that,
it is legitimate exercise and that's how I tell myself I'm multitasking,
I'm doing my game playing while I'm doing some of my exercise. Right.
Amanda and I, and it works out great. And while boxing,
boxing, virtual reality games are really incredible, um,
and you really do get a great workout.
The only problem is that the knuckles in the wrong position,
like when you're holding the handles and you're throwing punches,
even if you turn your knuckles over, the gloves kinda come out like this.
Yeah. Might have to twist your hand sideways. Yeah.
My problem with the boxing games is they also are a tremendous exercise.
You know,
you get in there and you run through the drills and get in there and you're
feeling really, I really kind of worked over at the end of it,
but from a purely interaction tactical level, I am, you know,
you don't hit anything for real you unless you're too close to your guardian
boundary and you punch the wall. I, so it fuels,
I lose some of the immersion on a lot of the VR experiences where you're sort of
miming and interaction, whether it's flipping switches that don't exist or no,
or throwing punches in boxing,
we might have some room for improving that with improved haptics in the future
where right now the controllers can make a little buzz in your palm and that
seems to work pretty well. When you slice through something,
you get a little sense of like, oh, I've kind of cut through it,
but it doesn't give you, you know, that kind of impact sense.
And I've suggested that we only have small motors, small batteries,
so you can't put really hefty things, a forced feedbacks.
But I've suggested that there might be something if you are winding up a spring
in some way there that a very sharp pop of feedback could give you that sense
where uh,
there's a lot of sort of a kinesiology things where a little hit in some way
will almost make you retract your hand.
And I kind of hand wavy suggest that boxing games might really benefit from
something like that.
So you throw the punch and you feel a pop in the palm of your hand and that
gives a much better sense of, you've actually connected for something. Well,
I think a great solution would actually be real boxing glove with more internals
because first of all it would aid in your exercise because it would be heavy.
Like if you could get an 18 ounce boxing glove and as you're moving here,
you're pushing that weight in the air, you really get a great workout that way.
Sometimes my son and I will take out strap on weights on our shoulders or in our
arms for a beat Saber. And yeah,
that really does make you think if you've got five pound weights there,
you're really thinking about not flicking but finding the optimal looping
pattern that goes through everything. That's kind of Andrei for good shoulders.
Yeah. Shoulders especially, you know, keeping him up like that. You know,
the boxing thing would be great and you have plenty of room inside that glove to
put some sort of a haptic feedback system so that you know,
as you did make contact with the thing, it gave you a sense of it in your hand.
Um,
the other thing I was thinking of in terms of martial arts is that I know you
have a background in martial arts grappling martial arts, right? Yeah. Yeah. Um,
that wouldn't be so good for that unless you had some sort of a working dummy
that was programmed that I think could be possible. Yeah.
I actually made a pitch that what I would like to see from a martial arts
standpoint there is immersive instructionals where the I am when you set up the
modern camera's right for the one 80 stereo I am VR.
It does give you this extra sense of depth that for a lot of things like if
you're looking at instructional,
sometimes it's a little hard to see exactly where the hands are in the different
areas.
And I think that there's some value for a lot of training aspects for virtual
reality. And in fact that's like Walmarts,
you doing a ton of work with that and there are a lot of companies that I am,
one of the side effects of that of putting a VR headset on is you are forced to
pay attention where if you're a company like Walmart training people,
you expect, most people wind up having their phone out.
They're not paying attention but put them inside the headset they have,
it's almost the clockwork orange stretching in the eyes out.
They have no choice but to pay attention.
But if it's important and you're training them for something that matters,
this is a, you know what you want.
But when I was thinking about things like I am, I am,
you know like I remember watching some judo instructionals for things and like
male Olympian level stuff. It just goes by so fast you just blink and it's gone.
I but a lot of things that I did in VR for some of the video stuff was giving
you this almost super power sense of time where you freeze frame and then being
able to like slowly frame forward, frame back, jog forward.
And when you've got an immersive sense here that really feels like an
interesting godlike power, you're sitting here just like stop time, step, step,
step, roll back, look closely at it, you know,
run forward and almost anything physical that you want to train people to do is
going to have some benefits for things like that.
And that's something that we're,
we're still just really at the early days of exploring that for making a
difference where people's training. Yeah. I think sparring, um,
you could have something that would throw strikes at you and you could move away
from those strikes and hit it leg kick it, do things along those lines.
The problem would be that you're not hitting anything because the only problem,
yeah. But there's certainly some valuable things you could do there.
And I have a friend that has a stick fighting background.
When I showed him beat Saber, he was like, oh,
immediately you have to do some stick training thing for this. And yeah,
clearly we are, even if you're not hitting things there,
but that sense of getting the motion,
figuring out how to move around the situational awareness.
And there's probably some things to do there.
It is a stretch to imagine some kind of a head mounted display involved in
actual grappling in any way, but I that's the big story. Yeah,
because also you would have the thing,
the only thing that I was thinking is you could have like a dummy,
like a robot mechanized dummy that has crude movement like butt but does
understand it can throw punches and kicks and it's programmed and you could kind
of spar with this thing in a virtual world and that thing also connects to the
system so it understands where you are and understands what you're doing with
the alerts. Robots, punching people, that could go poorly very poorly. Yeah,
it could go very poorly, but it could also be awesome.
But you could imagine perhaps again,
the augmented reality systems that we have today are finding most of their value
in training and it's for people like jet engine mechanics,
but you could imagine scenarios like that where you're training something like
martial arts where it's looking through and it's not making you a fully
simulated thing, but even if you're working through a drill with someone,
if it's basically drawing the outline of your arm goes here, your leg goes over.
Here I am. Again, training is one of the value areas that is working out.
A visualization is very important in martial arts.
I mean shadow boxing is already a huge part of a,
of a strikers learning like learning how to visualize and that's what they're
doing.
That's where they're supposed to do and when you see a good fighter shadow
boxing, they're sort of recreating these movements.
If you had a virtual reality headset and you had an actual opponent in front of
you, I think it would be way more lifelike and actually way more beneficial.
In fact, there are a bunch of football teams that are using VR for some of their
training, which largely is kind of visualizing the way plays are going to go.
It's not like they have virtual versions of everything,
but that sense of being able to get in to see what it would look like when it's
going right to kind of lock it into your mind has some value.
It seems to me that something like the void, which is really fun to do,
you could see in the future as technology improves having quite like
competitions in some sort of enormous warehouse
with other players. That's been one of the real visions from uh,
from early days. And in fact last year we,
we cobbled together a demo at oculus connect, our big I kind of convention,
which is next to the new ones next month here. Uh,
but we had a large area set up and you had this game called dead and buried,
which is kind of a cowboys Zombie shooting thing. Uh,
but we had a bunch of people that could play in one common,
enormous shared area. And it was amazingly cool. And everybody's like, well,
when do we get to play with this?
And this was all held together with duct tape sort of experience.
That's a lot of hard work to turn it real. But this warehouse scale stuff,
there are a number of companies that are trying to do this with various bits of
technology. I actually pulled something that idea of I, that was,
you know, where you could set up,
people are crouching behind real things in their virtual headset.
This is all kind of Zombie Western themed stuff.
And they can put their hand on real things there. They can move around,
draw a beat on people. And then you've got another person there with a tablet,
which is a window into the virtual world.
So they could look at that and see the whole, uh,
the way it's all drawn in style, the way that people are rendered inside it.
So there is, yeah,
this is again the amazing stuff you can do outside of your home where you get
the VR stuff that you wind up doing inside your home and then you figure out
what things can you do if you're willing to set up a dedicated place space.
And Yeah, this is people not moving around too much.
It's mostly kind of a cover based thing.
But there are companies that have people kind of charging around in pads and you
know, with a virtual world that they can skin and all sorts of different ways.
And that's, it's all exciting and as, oh,
so here's what we're getting an image of what it looks like to the people that
are playing it.
So and as things get more and more accurate in terms of what you're seeing and
more realistic,
you could conceivably be jumping up and down on boxes and running off ladders
and things along those lines and actually doing it in the virtual world as well
as in the real world. Yeah. So right now, like if you've done the void,
you can tell there's like a little gap between reality and you know,
you wouldn't want to do like a diving grab at a ladder rung, but it's,
you can see that there are things that we need to fix to get there,
but that's all possible. There's no can't be done sort of thing there.
And eventually you won't even need to be holding a controller.
It'll be able to track your whole body just from cameras and work,
all the kind of computer vision magic out from that.
And you will then be able to set up these wonderful skin virtual environments.
Yeah,
that's why I was thinking like East sports in terms of like an actual sports
sport,
like e-sports in terms of like doing something on a soccer field with a bunch of
people with virtual reality and they're playing some sort of heart,
horrific nightmare dystopian environment, Zombie game,
like whatever, you know, fill in the blank with your imagination. Yeah,
that's totally going to be here. Wow. That's how far away are we from that?
So a lot of it depends on kind of company plans where we don't have people
pester us about the, the technical hooks for things like,
and the people that are doing it themselves, like the void,
they put their own tracking technology on top of it because I,
ours isn't set up publicly in a way that they can do that.
So it's a lot of work for people to do it.
We will eventually commercialize it so that you can set things up more easily
out of the box I am.
But a lot of these then become entrepreneurial business plans of like, okay,
who's going to go raise the the tens of millions of dollars to set up and do it?
Right. But it's on the cusp of being,
it's not a technical problem now. It's not a technical impossibility.
No new research really needs to be done,
but there's still lots of challenges to work out.
So it's more about figuring out if you can get the business plan to close,
you can make the technology work.
How do you have time to do other things?
Like how did you get involved in grappling?
How do you have time to turbocharge Ferrari's? Like where,
where do you come up with the extra time to do all those other things?
So you know, I like to tell people that I,
one of my pitches is like you should always get enough sleep like I am,
I do not work well. Like I said, I can't work more than 13 hours if I,
if I don't get eight hours of sleep, I also start falling down.
But there's a lot of hours left in the week after your eight hours of sleep
there. I like on the martial arts side, it's, it is kind of interesting where I,
I wrestled in junior high and I did sort of Midwest YNC a judo back then.
I wasn't any kind of a phenom. I was, you know,
sort of a second place finisher for most of it.
But it was still weird enough that the co kind of,
the school geek was pretty good at that type of stuff. I am,
I messed up my knees a little bit doing that.
And in retrospect I wish I had pushed on a little bit more with that.
Where in recent years I sorta tried to challenge the wrestler ethos,
the embrace the grind to people where it's just like discipline is something.
I was always obsessed, but I could've done with a little more discipline.
I am when I was younger and I probably would've been better off if I had,
I kind of stuck through some of the, the wrestling side of things I am,
but I got back into it in my thirties where it was kind of something,
I'm just again, one of the between projects. Well,
what interesting thing do I want to take a look at?
And I looked up some of the local judo places and it was interesting where the
place that I wound out, it was called Besera judo.
And I had come again from Midwest y MCA judo, which is just kind of, you know,
you go and you learn your moves and it's, I, it's not that serious,
but this was a tie, you know, he was a Cuban Olympia and that, and it's still,
Judah's mostly kids you get mostly I kind of teenage kids coming in,
but I go in there and he's just yelling at the kids and berating them.
It's like, get up, grab the g and all this stuff. I'm much more serious,
a training environment. But I got in there and it's like, hey,
I did wrestling and judo back when I was a teenager, you know,
20 years ago at that point. Uh,
but I got on the mat and rolled and I had enough kind of wrestler instinct
memories that I, you know, I'd go down,
I'd base out and then the guy would roll me over and Armbar me like three times
in a row. Cause you know, early teens,
I YMC they didn't teach you the arm bars or anything. I am, but that was enough.
It's like, Hey, I was having a good time with that.
And so I did what I always do on something. I studied, you know,
I went and said, well, okay, I, you know, let's learn these armbars and things.
And I got the, you know,
the instructionals and the tapes and started working my way back through that
and got pretty good at that.
And then my wife for Christmas one year got me a year of private lessons with
Carlos Machado. Yeah.
And that was where I certainly took me up several levels.
I was in a situation where I had, uh, Armadillo Aerospace,
my rocketry company at the time, we had enough space.
So I had a whole bunch of mats set out there and I would work with Carlos and
one of the other guys there on Saturdays.
And he really tuned me up where I had, uh,
I had a really good straight arm bar that was my goto move for everything and
against most of the judo people that I, it was just,
most of them wouldn't know what hit them on that.
I would just be able to get that over and over again.
And there was a period there where I had I am, you know,
I'd go mix it up at the club on one day.
And then I had judo with one of my coaches and other day and then Carlos on
Saturday. And there was a period there where I was pretty dangerous.
Although I was, I was always one of the,
I never did work out proper flow kind of,
but just the way to just kind of roll effortlessly. I was always a very tense,
aggressive. I kind of grappler and uh,
an interesting thing about that where you know, you know,
from rolling with any of the really good guys, I like rolling with Carlos,
it's always happy fun,
he's smiling and you always think you should be able to do something but just
actually can't. But in contrast with that, one time when I went to Japan,
I stopped in at the Coda cod,
you know the home of judo got at the ancestral land of judo and you know it's
funny.
Were talking with a friend about that I that also did some judo where you'd
think that that should be like going to the Jedi temple.
It should be this logistic thing,
but it looks like an old middle school when you go there until you actually get
out onto the mats there. But I remember I did some rolling with an old judo guy,
you know,
gray haired guy practicing his English with me and it was shocking how different
it was versus rolling with Carlos were still, he was way, way better than me,
but it was a sense where when I was rolling with him,
I just felt I had no options. Like for whatever reason,
I was just all with bound up and I couldn't do anything until eventually gets my
arm and I tap as opposed to the fluidness with Carlos where I'm like running
around thinking, oh if I just do this, maybe I'll be able to get, you know,
get around playing. Yeah, yeah. Just, he was very famous for playing.
Oh my instructors, his brother John, you said you messed your knees up.
So of course back then I,
I had tweaked my knees in some way where it wasn't bad enough that I had,
maybe at the time I should have had surgery, but I did.
And I had a little Jujitsu training. No,
this was actually back in one in wrestling and one in judo when I was a
teenager.
And so that's why I've still got these little stick legs cause I could never
lift what, you know, heavy weights because my knees gave me problems.
So I wound up with strong upper body and really nothing on the, on
the legs. Did you get your knees MRIs? I never did. You know, again,
this was back in the [inaudible]. You not embrace MRIs? Well, so again,
this was the eighties [inaudible] yeah, they did. But it's like, you know,
I was not, you know, it was teenage me back then and it was like, OK,
my knees hurt and my knees hurt a little bit. No.
So by the time I was in my thirties, they generally felt okay.
So that was when I decided I'm going to go back into judo and I,
and it's been all right for quite a while and it's, you know, it's interesting.
There were a lot of people are surprised that I care about this.
Like I tweeted about going to the UFC in Dallas and there were a number of
people that are like, you know, this is shocking and disappointing that you,
you know, that you like, you know, seeing people harm each other. Hi, add.
There's one interesting thing at the club where there was a new kid that came in
and I could tell he was probably here because his dad thought he should toughen
up a little bit. Uh, you know, a very not forceful person. I am.
And when he found out who I was, he said,
what is someone like you doing here?
And it just didn't compute for him that I somebody that was a technical I kind
of brainy sort of person would appreciate like kind of rolling at a judo club
and, and I probably agree with his, his father that there's a,
there is a value to getting, uh,
getting people into a sense where they felt the physicality of it.
They've had to push as hard as they can and maybe not get through and learn
that.
Find the extents of what you can and can't do and what the limits of your body
are. And I think that's good for almost everybody to get that at some level.
I mean, even if you don't care about the competition and the winning,
but kind of knowing what's possible and the different limits there I think is
valuable.
I agree wholeheartedly and I love the fact that you got into it because I would
like to encourage so many more people to experience that there are,
there's many things going on simultaneously.
There's a technical aspects of the various moves that have to understand the
points of leverage and how to get to a superior position.
But there's also the physical exertion aspect where you're,
you're managing your body's resources and you have a finite amount of energy and
you can't burn it all out quickly.
So there's this sort of management game that you're playing and then on top of
it, it's like you, you have to be able to be uncomfortable. It's,
you have to be able to put yourself in a good state of mind while you're
uncomfortable.
And so many of those lessons learn from that are applicable to everyday life and
they, they give you a higher threshold for discomfort,
a higher threshold for pushing through obstacles and understanding boundaries
and how to overcome them and how to increase your physical engine,
how to strengthen your, your meet vehicle lesson about, you know,
sometimes you're the hammer and sometimes you're the nail.
And a lot of people do go through much of their life. I am, you know,
without ever really internalizing that where it's always a participation trophy
or whatever.
But it's like sometimes you get your ass kicked ad that can bring it.
You can come back stronger after. Yes. It's good for you.
It's actually good for you. And it's a,
an amazing comraderies particularly in grappling. I've found that grappling,
the comradery is much nicer than striking.
I came from a striking background because the thing about striking all there is
a camaraderie,
a deep camaraderie with people that you would go and compete with.
You're hurting each other. Yeah.
Whereas in grappling you're not really hurting each other the same way and you
can kind of do it full blast and you appreciate each other because iron truly
does sharpen iron in that there are so many times I remember just driving back
from the IMF, from judo where I just have the big smile on my face.
Just thinking that was really great. And it's like the judo club was in AI,
you know, a little bit of a sketchier area of town. So my wife was always like,
you can never drive your Ferrari's to judo practice.
So how did you get involved with turbocharging Ferrari's? Like what?
Because that's a no, no. In the Ferrari world. Right.
And definitely the Porsche world,
they sort of have always encouraged modifications of the cars.
Even from the early days, people have hot rotted Porsches,
but when you fuck around with Ferrari, people get really upset at you.
So my path through the cars is interesting. Where I, as a younger kid,
I was not a car guy. You know,
I had a stepbrother with the Lamborghini posters and all of that,
and I just did not care. You know, I was all about computers.
I knew what I wanted. I would much rather have the, you know, a new apple.
Then I look at a Porsche or something like that.
And my first car was this very boring Joe Volkswagen Jetta. And it's like, Hey,
it drives me around. I was just fine. Somebody wrecked, you know,
ran into it and looking around for the next car. I, my,
I like uncle in law or something. Had I,
I worked on cars and he had an old British MGB in his garage.
And you're familiar with British sports cars and you know,
in many ways they're just terrible, terrible cars. But I fell in love with it.
It was just beautiful. And I, and I started,
I had to learn all about cars at that point because you know,
the clutch master cylinder broke the very first day that I had it.
And just everything is breaking all the time and it's a pathetic weak little
engine. But you're like, oh wait,
can make it a little bit faster by doing some of these different things.
And I went through the, like many other things that I've had in my life.
I go through sort of this larval learning stage where I start reading the hot
rod magazines and graduate to circle track or something. And again,
this is Midwest Missouri where I grew up, I,
so I learned all the basic ins and outs of the cars.
There I am and then I go on,
I started software and start getting successful and I do the sort of natural
upgrade from an MGB after it. I, after it gearbox eats itself,
I buy a Miata,
which is sort of the modern slick version of a British sports car.
And that was going along, I, you know, okay. For me, I enjoyed it,
but almost on a whim,
one time I went into the Ferrari dealership in Dallas and here I am at,
I thought I was like Wolfen Stein days.
So I guess I was I 20 years or 20 years old or something and I'm in a tee shirt
and ripped jeans and I walk into the Ferrari dealership and say,
kind of sell me a Ferrari. I am. And they humored me and they,
I kind of walked around. I, you know,
we looked at the different things and a lot of the,
the Ferrari's at that time in the early nineties, I'm, I am, you know,
three 48 and Monte yells, I didn't really like all that much, but, uh,
one of the ones in the backer, Raj, they had a, for a three 28,
which is kind of, you know, the fancier version of the,
the magnum Pi car from the earlier days.
And I thought it was just the most beautiful car I am, you know, this is,
I really wanted to get it. And when I wound up buying it,
it was interesting because the salesman gave me a little bit of a talk where he
said, you know,
if someone in a corvette pulls up next to you and that kind of rubs their
engine, just Kinda hang your hand out the window.
Like you got a thousand horsepower under the hood.
And that didn't sit well with me. That was like this idea of like,
he kind of knew that those cars weren't actually as fast as they looked or I,
you know,
or their reputation would have and that there's this play that you would do to
just kind of not get into a situation where it doesn't hold up to its looks.
And I was like, no, I don't like that.
And so I wound up kind of calling around to all the different shops in Dallas
where it's like, okay,
I've got a Ferrari three 28 I want to make it a little faster.
And I had done all this stuff on my MGB back in the day.
So I know the things they,
that you wind up doing with the intake and exhaust and Cam timings and uh,
the options there. But they were all basically horrified. Like,
you just don't do this to a Ferrari.
And like the only suggestion that came out was a,
we can put an Italian two B exhaust on it and that'll, you know,
don't make it sound better and maybe it's good for a couple of horsepower or
something. Those are things that people largely do for the aesthetics. I've,
you know, whether it's oral or visual with it. Uh, and that's not a big move.
And right at about that time, John Romero at the office had I picked up,
there was a copy of Turbo magazine back in the day and there was an article
about an old replica kind of race car and done by a local company in Dallas
called nor would auto sport or nor at auto craft. And I thought, well,
he's right here. I'll call him up. And so I call him up,
I get Bob Knorr rode on the phone and I start going through my pitch.
I've got a three 28 I'd like it to be a little fast or what do you think we can,
and before I could even finish he said we'll put a turbo on it. Like yeah,
now we're talking. And that was the beginning of,
I am kind of all the science project experiments.
What does a three 28 have standard horsepower?
I think in the the best probably the European trim,
it was probably around 300 horsepower.
And would you get it up to the turbocharger?
So we went through a number of steps of this and this is all swapping out all
the computer electronics. I'm different turbos.
And eventually I melted the engine in it when it was at like 500 or so.
And I went through a long history of melting many pistons in the different
devices in different cars.
But that wound up this decade long set of interesting experiments there.
That was my gateway drug into working on this. And we're like, okay,
we've made all this power in this system. I,
we know it's kind of at the limits of a lot of things in the chassis.
After we melted the engine there,
we tuned it back down a little bit and that's the way so many engineering things
wind up going. You go it until it breaks.
Then you dial it back a little bit and you stay there.
It must have been radically fast for three 28 it's very light, right? Yes.
The curb weight, ah, lately it's not super light.
I think it was like 3,200 pounds and uh, but yeah, it, it,
you could really feel it rear back when you went into it.
And I'm at high speed is a little bit Dardy if you start getting up in one 54
miles an hour for that. So we thought, well, what's the next level?
Where do we go from here?
So I had done a twin turbo job on a Testarossa before,
which is a much wider car. I, you know, stock,
they would go 180 190 miles an hour with the normal for our atrium and,
and it was a bigger five liter flat 12 so there's a lot more possibility for
doing things there. So I got, I got a Testarossa and we said, all right,
we're going to do the twin turbo job with inner coolers with the new, you know,
the new engine management systems.
And we went through this long string of upgrades through this,
which generally was like, okay, we melted the Pistons,
we broke the input shaft all these times. But at its top form,
in peak, I still have the dyno sheet four,
it was like 1,009 horsepower at the rear wheels.
None of this crane chorus power talk. This was, I, you know,
over a thousand horsepower at the Rio reels. And it was amazing.
That sounds ridiculous. What does standard horsepower with those?
It was like three 80 or something like God. So it was a huge, huge difference.
And you had all these things like, you know,
he couldn't launch like a dragster for our aid gear shifts or you know,
really gears in a blender sorta thing and you've got a dog leg first.
So it would not do a really fast zero to 60.
But if you are on the highway I am and you could just downshift to fourth.
You could go from 50 to 150 faster than anybody's business.
It was with that much horsepower. I, you know,
I would run down superbikes it would, uh, it would just be faster than anybody.
It was shockingly fast. How did is handsome? Really pretty well,
so we had bigger tires, some stiffer suspension on it.
It was not designed to be a, a super track car.
I had taken all of my Ferrari's to the tracks, but I was no,
no pretentions about being any kind of an SCCA champion or anything.
But I could wing them. I could move them around the tracks reasonably well.
But the main thing about this was this just ungodly amount of power.
It was this, see Jesus' effect when somebody died,
takes a ride in and you're like, okay, we're going,
you ready for this and you have enough space.
And for all of those years that did software,
our building was positioned I off of this,
we had this long highway access road that led down to it and I mostly,
more often than not,
I was working kind of night owl hours and this car was so loud.
I am kind of obnoxious in retrospect, but I am,
I had this personal dragstrip basically every day when I would go there and
everybody in the building could tell, it's like, oh, John's coming.
Which was sort of the signal better get to work and look busy by the time he
gets up here. I bet it was,
especially in the early days before we got some traction,
control dialed in it good,
get really squirrely just because when the boost would come up fast enough on
there, it would tend to throw the car a little bit sideways. And I'm, you know,
I'm happy that I can look back and say, I, you know,
I never spun a car on the ice, one of the big cars on the streets.
I did spend my little MGB I when I was learning how to drive as a teenager,
but I never did that with the big Ferrari's on public roads.
Although there was one time at the,
the motor sports ranch when I pitched my f 50, like through the Infield,
just spinning it around over and over. And we're like, well,
there's the world's most expensive lawn mower now.
What did you do with those cars? So, uh,
the first one I gave the three 28 I gave away for the red annihilation
tournament. So that was I, that fresh one that wasn't,
so now he wound up, uh, that was,
there were some pictures of that going around recently where it was a little bit
weird, sketchy because I, it was a turbocharge theirs,
it really wasn't technically illegal in Dallas. Most of the time I, you know,
we would make it legal sometimes,
but much of the time it probably wouldn't have passed an emissions test and it
really wouldn't have passed a California emissions test.
So he wound up using it as he had it sort of in the lobby of his company for a
while is kind of a conversation piece. And he did,
I think eventually wound up selling it.
I think I got a message from someone last year that still had it.
So it's still functional at this point,
which is saying something because it had an early,
almost one-off Paul tech engine control system that probably no one can do
anything too right now.
You'd probably have to completely replace it if something went wrong with it.
The Testarossa. Uh,
we eventually detuned it a little bit down to a six or 700 horsepower or
something and somebody bought it from me and I felt he might've been buying more
car than he should have at that point. Well basically it's going to break again.
It's going to have problems, you know,
he wanted it and I think that he got some great satisfaction out of it,
but I know it broke again on him later and I,
and I think he had to get rid of it. I know after that then I had a,
I had a Ferrari f 40, which is beautiful, beautiful car.
And that was the only car that I didn't really modify. I am,
all we did was turn the waste gate and closed, lock that off.
So it was making all basically race trim at 40 there.
And the afford is an interesting car and that it has, in the, those early days,
the turbos weren't nearly what they are right now. It was a small engine,
2.8 liter because it was specked for racing. It really was sort of a race car.
And if you didn't ring its neck, it was a pretty slow car.
If you just like idled it off, it felt like a Honda civic.
It was terrible at the low end you had to really rev it up and slip the clutch
out, get it up on boost. But it was,
it was a great car because it was like this amazing race car that you're driving
around on the road.
And that was still where it didn't even have internal door handles.
They had the little pull cord inside there,
which led to the point where there was one time I was getting it valet parked
and you could tell the valet that had to go get the car.
For me it's like this is okay. Highlight of the week.
He gets to go drive a Ferrari at 40 and he pulls it up and he can't figure out
how to open the door. So all of his brand, you know,
everyone else working with him or just kind of looking at him and I had to come
over and tell them how to to get it out.
So that went from the highlight to like the worst day of his, his time there.
Do you still do that? You still have cars like that? So No.
Right now I am all about the Tesla where I have, I,
I have a p 100 d and I think it's the best car I've ever owned by far.
So I've gone through all of these hyper exotics and I love my Tesla.
I have the same and it's as fast as anything.
It's the fastest car I've ever driven in my life. So compared to my, you know,
my supercars there that the Tesla is much quicker off the start,
which most of the time that you're driving is, you know,
my point about the talk about how antisocial the old cars were aware I did.
You could not just go use this. You would have to plan ahead where okay,
you make sure that you've got enough room.
If you have a traction issue going here,
you're going to cover a huge amount of distance. It was so loud,
you really wouldn't want to do it in most places.
But the Tesla is so magical where I had one of the first roadsters and one of
the, when I was letting some other people take it out for drives, I said,
you're driving a rail gun, which essentially you are,
it's this electromagnetic pull on the car and you just push,
push the throttle down and it just goes and it's this amazing feeling and it's
not antisocial. Every stop sign you stop at, you've got traction control.
It's not burning rubber.
You could just floor it every time you stop and it's amazing.
It just brings a smile to your face. It is this happiness machine.
While the stunning acceleration is so confusing to people.
I've like, my wife hates it, my phone, I've had people in my car and I go,
you ready for this? And I stomped the gas and then just go, Jeez us.
Yeah cause it doesn't seem real. It doesn't seem like a car that looks like a,
you know, a nice four door sedan should be able to do that.
So that launch is definitely really something.
But I am compared to like if you're, if you're already moving the,
the old Testarossa with a thousand horsepower was a very different beast where
that Jesus' sense that you get at the very beginning.
It's that magnified extended for quite a while as you're running up through 150
miles an hour or so. And I am, but yeah, I'm signed up for the, uh,
the next to the 2020, the next roadster that's supposed to come out. So,
you know, I wouldn't put too much. I, you know, they'll probably slip, you know,
the Tesla is like, I, you know,
like game companies and so much of the other stuff I think they were saying it
might be, I don't want to mistake, we should probably look it up here,
but I'm on the list. It's going to get here as soon as it can.
And I want the rocket boost addition also with the extra compress gas tanks.
Yeah. What does that gonna do? What does that extra rocket boost?
And so the idea is that I,
cars with this much power are completely traction limited,
especially at launch era where you have no aerodynamic forces.
So you could have infinite horsepower and you're not going to get off the line
to 30 miles an hour any faster than what the p 100 will do given the same amount
of tires. So I, there's a few things that you could do with that.
You can be like a rocket, you can throw something out the back.
So you need no traction at all. Rockets don't use ions,
they don't require traction,
they don't even require air and they can work in space.
So most rockets of course have all sorts of propel ends.
You really don't generally want to be around a that are either cryogenic or
toxic or generally problematic. I,
but the idea here is that for space x,
they've developed a lot of these really cutting edge, state-of-the-art,
compressed gas tanks,
which are the same types of things you use for compressed gas vehicle tanks
except much higher. I much more mass efficient.
So the idea is you just fill him with air,
pump them up and it's like an enormous balloon. You know you,
oh you let go of the balloon, it flies around the room. I will.
When you've got 10,000 psi of air and you put a rocket nozzle on it and
essentially you just open the valve and it can push you forward with and almost
arbitrary amount of thrust.
The amount of thrust is only determined by how big the throat of the rocket
nozzle is,
which means that sometimes you see these industrial accidents where if like the
end of a compressed gas tank falls off. I,
so it's got a hole like this big and all of the gas is coming out of there.
It all blows out in a very short amount of time, but that can launch those,
you know those bottles like really high into the air through walls.
It's limited only by how big of an outlet you want to get it.
I don't know what they're specking this as for how much they can do.
But there's an interesting thing about that where you can have it just throw the
thrust. I completely horizontally,
but I suspect it would be slightly better if they angle it up a little bit.
So you get a little bit of downforce so you can both steer better.
But in the early things, especially on the roadster,
you've got more torque available from the electric motor,
then you have traction.
So we would wind up with net best acceleration by a little bit of downforce so
the engine can actually throw all of its power at it from the electric motor.
And then all the rest of it is horizontal thrust. Now ideally,
of course you would gimbal it and then you could start moving it around and vary
your downforce and thrust. And I, you know,
you could take this all the way where you put them on all four corners and you
could bunny hop your car. That's not spec for the current vehicle,
but you could take that exact same system,
put more of them on there and you could control that,
which is like all the work that I was doing in rocketry started out with these I
computer controlled rocket vehicles that would use the rockets and steer them
under control and they could sit up there and the hover kind of right in front
of you move around, translate and land and you could totally do that on a car.
You wouldn't be able to do it for very long.
But the idea of being able to make sort of a Batmobile leap or something to be
able to like get away,
get over something that is plausible and would be interesting to do. Wow. Look,
how far do you think you could travel?
So it totally depends on how much propel it. In this case,
cold gas doesn't give you very much. So no, it's not, would not be flying car,
but that's why I'm saying you could make a hopping car.
You could make something that takes a leap,
has enough propel it to be able to do a steady descent.
So it's an impulse up and then decelerate so you're not wrecking and lets the
suspension take the rest of it at the end. And somebody should do that.
That's something that the world should be able to see that happening.
So similar to what they're doing currently with jet packs where they have a very
short window of time where they can apply the thrusters.
So it's interesting to compare the,
the history of that where in the early days from back in the 60s there were
people that made these rocket packs that used concentrated hydrogen peroxide,
which is one of the easiest rocket propellant to work with. And it's what I,
you know, my company used for a number of years. I am,
the great thing about that is it's one liquid mano propellant as opposed to by
propellant where you need like liquid oxygen and kerosene.
So it's just one liquid and essentially you just spray it through this special
mesh of catalyst and it decomposes to really hot steam and lots of it.
So the easiest rocket in the world to make maintaining the catalyst as a
problem.
But fundamentally you need a tank pressurized up and a valve that opens to kind
of go through that I am.
So they would make these things where they would have a couple of nozzles and
they could slowly open the throttle and let them up and you'd see the people
kind of hovering around.
And what's important about this is that is completely unstable.
There is no sense of kind of eye stability that you get even on a helicopter
which is very unstable.
You still have a big spinning mass and its got some directional stability.
If you're flying on rocket thrust alone, you can flip end over in trivially.
So the people that did these eye, they were like stunt men,
people that were used to doing this and still almost everybody wound up breaking
legs having problems like this. Uh,
because they could only last for about 30 seconds,
usually about 20 seconds you have this backpack full of I,
maybe you're carrying 50 60 pounds of propel it and all that gets you is 20
seconds of flight time. So they would plan out all of these things. It's like,
all right, we're going to fly into the Olympic stadium or whatever.
As this very short,
it's an arc from here coming down to here because you just do not have much time
to loiter around and try to fix things.
What makes the modern jetpacks that people are working on so much better than
that is the way a jet works is instead of like a rocket where everything that
it's throwing out, the nozzle is stored in a tank. Jets work by using the air,
uh, as for oxygen,
which is the bulk of what you wind up consuming and then only carrying kerosene
or some kind of fuel jet fuel to burn with that.
So that lets them get several minutes of flight from things like this,
even from potentially smaller tanks. I am now, they're still, I have,
it looks like they're still largely doing it with highly skilled operators that
are working, that,
that are on the edge of wiping out at any given moment and you know, and wisely,
often flying over water and so on.
But there's no reason why that can't be computer control.
Then you see the amazing things that people are doing with. Now.
This is something that I think about where, uh,
it was pretty exciting the early days of the rocket stuff that I was doing where
you had a rocket that could hover and slowly move over. I,
there was one time we were flying at an Oklahoma airfield and we had this,
you know,
kind of good old boy reporter coming out there and we flew this rocket through
this trajectory. It was for the, the lunar lander challenge and was like, well,
there's something you don't see every day.
And it was this very shocking thing about this giant 2000 pound rocket just kind
of picking up and moving over and landing, but the same all-girl them's like,
I was proud of myself doing those.
I had learned all the necessary control dynamics and embedded systems
programming and stuff to to do that code. I'm,
and it was doing what we needed it to do.
But you look at what people do with drones today and it's just magnificent.
These aerial ballets have synchronized hundreds of drones doing all these
gymnastics and you could do that with the rocket engines or the jet engines or
something like that and they could be doing movie style iron man stuff.
I as soon as you're willing to let the computer trust,
I know that it's going to do the right thing,
but that's the key difference where we were able to make amazing progress for
what we were doing because we were willing to build and destroy a couple of
vehicles a year and I was very proud of that for a long time,
for like at least eight or nine years. We built him,
destroyed two rocket vehicles. Each year we learned something,
built another one and you know, threw it away. And these were, you know,
fairly expensive. They would cost us, I am, you know, the later ones in
the a hundred something thousand dollars and you have to know that you're
building it, it's going to turn into a smoking pile of wreckage. I,
at some point, you know the vehicle will be expended in the learning process.
But what's made the drone so much better is all of these people that do these
university teams doing control dynamics.
They have a closet full of drone wreckage because the drones are so amazingly
cheap that you just have these commercial, these commoditized parts.
You put them together, they try something that's up, we blew them, you know,
we crashed another drone toss into the closet, grab another one out.
And that's a real lesson about pace of the, you know,
the acceleration that you can get by reducing the I at the time to experiment.
Are you done with the rocket world?
So I used to think about it a lot more even after I was kind of out of it where
I, you know, getting out of rockets.
My wife is wiser than I am in many ways where she had put a kind of a limit.
We had, this is John's crazy rocket money and I have, you know,
you are not going to bankrupt the family.
I've by pursuing rocket dreams and I was doing it part time and eventually we
got to the point where we had,
we had one year where we had an operating profit for a little aerospace company.
We were working for a, you know,
we were doing some NASA and air force and rocket racing league. That was great.
These man rocket planes we built that. They got to fly around and you know,
have some racing with some stuff that I was very proud of. But I am,
we reached a point where there's this trap that a lot of companies like that can
get into and I saw a number of them in it where you go into this thinking that
we're going to change the world, we're going to do this massive thing.
We want to colonize space, all of this.
But you get stuck in this area where all right, there are opportunities for us.
We can get government contracts to do various work.
You know there's work we can do for NASA and Department of Defense, but,
and you tell yourself that,
well we'll do this and we'll be using their money to fund the real dream of our,
the rocket ships that we want to build.
But I've never seen it work out like that. You know, you wind up,
I kind of stuck in this drip feed of you can get a few new contracts and you can
keep the lights on and the government does this really largely intentionally
where they say it's good for the United States to have some level of grassroots
aerospace companies, the small technology companies.
It actually covers a whole bunch of material science and lots of different
things. It's good to have these small companies exist.
So the government doles out this drip feed of contracts where you can keep your
researchers and engineers kind of working, putting some things together. I,
and it was a fork in the road there.
We could have gone down that path but decided that no,
we were going to try like one more year. I'll put the money into it.
We're going to go for it. We need to, it's like suborbital or bust. I'm,
you know,
getting the a hundred kilometer reusable vehicles and we didn't quite make it,
you know, we got to like 92 kilometers and I'm, you know,
out in space some lovely pictures of like the,
the flare of the sun and spinning around in the black sky and bloot coming out
for reentry and things that I, I was proud of. But you know,
we just didn't quite make it and I was at that point where I had to say,
and it's like, all right, this is the, you know, the end of the road.
I did wind up selling most of the, the assets to some of the, uh,
the team members that raised some other funding to continue on. I am, but the,
one of my biggest lessons from that is I don't think I can do a proper job
splitting my focus part time between different things because I was still full
on, on it software and doing the gaming. I was like 40 hours.
I did in 20 hours that Armadillo and I,
and I just wasn't able to give it the focus that it needed.
I don't know how Ilan can, you know,
have five companies that he's involved in to some degree.
I think that me personally, I need to have some level of focus.
So I was saying if I go back into it, I want to do it full time. I have my,
my crazy ideas, I for things that I had, I'd like to try and rocketry,
but largely I think space x is doing an amazing job. I it is, again,
things sneak up on people. They don't notice the world changing around them,
but this was the science fiction future that we wanted in the fifties and
sixties you know,
we have a billionaire that's gone out and built the world's best rocket ship
that wants to go to Mars and is building the rocket ship to do that. You know,
this is, you know, this is the movie scenario. It's almost a no,
the only thing is in movies,
it wouldn't have taken the decade plus time that it takes if it somehow would've
been compressed into three or four years. So it takes longer in reality.
But even the things you want to see in the movies are actually happening here.
So I think space x is doing a great job and I am, you know,
I was da Ilan invited me by and he actually had me sitting in one of their
engineering meetings and I'm just throwing out random ideas to the people there
and I, I know I could kind of, you know, they'd be,
they'd be happy to have me working with them in some way,
but I'd be just another principal engineer on some way.
I am much more interested in being the crazy plan c in some way.
And if I thought there really needed to be a crazy plan C,
I have my ideas for scary mixed moto propellant rockets that might be super
cheap in some ways, might blow up horribly.
But it turns out that there are now a number of companies like I,
it's shocking now that there's another company like rocket lab that's been
successfully launching things into orbit and we almost haven't noticed and
remarked around it about it, where this is something that again,
prior to space x space launch was the domain of a half dozen national
governments. And now we have a few small companies.
Space X isn't small anymore, but we have, you know,
a few companies that have just gone and done that and that's pretty great.
So I am tempted to go back in. I have ideas that I'd like to try,
but I think it's in good enough hands right now,
but it's always a possibility in the future.
What does Jeff Bezos company trying to do? They're,
they're emulating space x some sort of a way, right? So yeah,
blue origin was now all I like.
All three of these have have origins back in similar periods of time.
Like at the very start of Armadillo when we had our,
just our very crude as things Ilan and one of his first guys came down and
visited us in Dallas and we talked about rockets and everything.
I then baseless came in somewhat later, initially very, very secretive.
I am and also very conservative where, uh, you know,
in their logo they've got a tour, a turtle basically.
And it was more or less saying we're going to take our time and do this.
And I did always think that was the wrong direction where I am.
That's a real hazard where you have a billionaire backer that says,
take your time. I am, you know,
unlike space x where space x was burning through all of Elan's money. I am,
Ilan had a large fraction of his fortune invested in this and he was down to the
last point where they blew up three rockets and it's like,
this one's got to make it or they're just not going to be able to get by.
And that's a very, very different work environment than I, you know, hey,
we've got a blank check. You know, we can take our time, we can do all of this.
I, and I know every time something goes wrong for space x, every time you know,
they have an explosion or a landing failure,
so many people are ready to jump on them.
But that's what's allowed them to make these really truly remarkable advances.
So the turtle approach is just not conducive to raw.
They've cranked it up more recently.
They've gotten serious about building full scale stuff.
So they sort of built the suborbital vehicle that, uh,
that I was on track to build that uh, it goes up to a kilometers,
talk about space tourism, carry people up. I do the Little Rye, like,
have you ever taken one of the zero g airplane rides? No. You should.
It's interesting. I this, this would be the, I,
you go do that and you get these little kind of parabolas of 20 seconds or so of
weightlessness where you can float around or you can get simulated Martian or
lunar gravity.
The idea of the suborbital space tourism would be that you go up there to a
hundred kilometers and plum it down and you've got about five minutes of zero
gravity floating around with space outside.
And that's the idea that that would be, you know, this remarkable experience.
And we had a bunch of companies that were sort of targeting this as the
direction that I, there's not much market for small satellite and you know,
these tiny micro set payloads. How do you close the business?
The pitch was always that, well if we have this reliable people want to do this,
it would call them like self-loading carbon payloads.
People will want to go in the world's tallest roller coaster and you'd say
originally the thinking was that'd be $100,000 which is like,
of course everybody's like, Whoa, that's like way too much.
But there's a lot of wealthy people in the world. It seems reasonable.
But one of the interesting life lessons I got from this,
when virgin finally came into this and they decided, well,
we're going to enter this, I am all of these little scrappy companies I've,
that didn't necessarily have much business knowhow or things like $100,000
sounds about right for the price for several rural tourism.
It's a nice round number, but virgin came in, you know Richard Branson,
and I was like, oh,
the price is $200,000 and everybody's still signed up with him.
That was a notable thing where reading your market correctly for that,
where that was the difference between a hundred thousand dollars maybe eking by
and covering your bases and everything, and $200,000 it's like, Oh,
you've actually got some profit margin there,
but now a decade has passed since that's gone on and there's no way they're
going to earn back their, all the investment that they've piled into that,
you know, if things take too long, you know, that's tangenting off here again.
But that's another one of the life lessons where I used to be known about the
catch line. You know, it'll be done when it's done. You know, when,
when we'll do m ship, when it's done, when we'll quake ship, when it's done.
And it felt good saying that in terms of,
that was sort of the being rebellious about we don't have any publisher that's
going to force us to be out in time for their quarterly earnings.
We're going to make sure we, we ship the game when it's actually done.
But the aspects of seeing I with a little bit more perspective now,
it's like if you're talking slipping a quarter, slipping six months, yeah,
great. That's definitely fine. But when you're talking about slipping years,
you know, when years go by,
the world changes around you in a way that being a kind of totalitarian about
it, it'll only ship when it's done.
I largely recant from that now where with a little bit more perspective time has
a physicality that you may not appreciate. And I have the two big reads on that.
I am seeing some of like virgin galactic,
they're never gonna make that money back.
They're looking into satellite launch for things now. But even the,
the last big game that I worked on it he had, which was rage, I'm,
we spent six years on that game and we went into that.
I am, it was using flashy new technology,
which there's some other life lessons about that I, but we had like,
we had an [inaudible] where we were game of show at e three but you know,
we kept on it didn't quite ship and by the time it got out the world had changed
around us. You know,
the technology decisions that were made for some earlier systems weren't
necessarily the right thing for the, the very latest ones.
We now had call of duty and battlefield coming out as these juggernauts that we
were competing with. And I look back as one of those real decisions.
I think we should have done whatever it would have taken to ship that two years
earlier, be less ambitious with some of the technologies and get it out earlier.
And I can even make reasonable cases for going back to the earliest games like
quake where quake was the first really traumatic game to ship internally where
we're still only talking like two year developments.
But at the time it felt really long and we had all sorts of internal strife for
things because we were trying to do so many things. It was, you know,
six degree of freedom rendering, modding I internet based game servers, I,
you know, three, six off models and it was a lot of stuff.
And I later looked back and said, you know,
we could have done half of those things in a Superdome and shipped it earlier
and then done the other half even better on a game coming in later.
And I still roll that over in my mind sometimes where I love quake and I love
doing,
I think all of those were doing what I think was the optimal game to ship at the
optimal time.
Quake was challenging and painful enough that maybe we could've done some things
slightly better there. I, you know,
popping a couple off the stack there to back to blue origin.
I think they spent a lot more time than they needed to in that kind of turtle
mode. But now they're building big serious things and I think they've probably
abandoned the space tourism stuff. They flew their thing.
It's like it looks good enough that some people could get in,
but right now it's interesting when you go from the game of $200,000,
I sell floating carbon payloads to billion dollar NASA contracts and it drives
your engineering in different ways. So I think they're now saying,
we don't want space x to run off and take it all for themselves and they're
scrambling a little bit to build their, bring their architectures to bear their,
well, that's got to be beneficial to everybody, right.
To have all these billion dollar companies compete,
particularly Bayzos with his unlimited bank account competing and for all of us
to watch these commercial space ventures take place.
It's really, really interesting.
So I do think that space is one of those things that I am,
you can make all the hard analytic arguments about, okay,
we've got communication satellites and all this stuff that like yo is doing with
I the the low satellite communication networks.
These are big important things that may be incredibly valuable,
but all of us that have done this at that level do really believe deeply at some
level that we do want humanity to not be tied to the earth.
You know there we want to be a multi planet or at least space habitat.
I am species where there's this sense that the world is disc retired now when
you have gps and it's kind of a weird thing when you,
you can look at gps with the numbers,
read out to all of this and say you are exactly here within a meter all in the
world. You can map the whole world and lay a texture over it.
In some ways it's squeezed some of the magic out of the world.
You know you had the lost city of El Dorado is probably not hiding,
you know in some place that has just had canopy cover for all of this because we
can turn it into a grid and walk through all of it if we need to and it leads
some people to a more fatalistic attitude than they should have about that.
The limits of growth, the limits of resources that you know,
we need to dial back our ambitions because the world is only so big and there's
too many people in it and I think they're wrong even on the single earth case
that there are so many resources here that people do not even appreciate.
But I think once you step outside of the earth and once you do have people on
the moon and Mars and that are doing things there,
there's a lot of reasons about eggs in one basket, sort of things,
asteroid and meal killer asteroids and stuff.
But just having humanity spread out more like that and knowing that I want
people to be able to look up at the moon,
a full moon and say there are people working up there,
there's another city up there and that's some place you might go later on.
I am for some reason, you know that you get on the next transport there.
And this is the,
the good old fashioned future of sort of the fifties and sixties that the Robert
Heinlein science fiction world of the future. You know,
the strong job engineers building the space fairing world.
And I realize,
I'm conscious of the fact that I have a foot in both camps here where, you know,
I'm building VR, which is kind of the stuck in the matrix sort of thing,
the dystopian modern science fiction future.
But a large part of me does still kind of hanker for this,
this old sense of like, no, the possibilities are unlimited.
Technology will save us, we can get there. It's a matter of engineering.
We can build what we want. We've never been in a better position before.
They're smarter people in the world today than there ever have been and that,
you know, it's unlimited. It's not this limited world that we're stuck in.
We can go, we can colonize Mars,
we can colonize the moods and we can make space stations.
And the fact that we now have idealistic billionaires building this,
that we don't have to go ahead and necessarily wrangled the votes in Ohio for
the NASA station in Houston or whatever. I think it's a fantastic thing.
I agree.
Do you have a longterm vision in terms of what you're trying to do with virtual
reality and octopus? So I do, and it's, I am, you know,
it's something that people,
some people read this the wrong way and react incorrectly to it.
Where I've said that my pitch for VR is that the, the,
the promise of VR is it's to make the world as you wanted,
where people do not have the, it's just,
it is not possible on earth to be able to give everybody all that they would
want. Not Everybody can have Richard Branson's private island.
There's just not enough private in and out of islands in the world to give them
to people. But even on a, a much more mundane level,
not everyone can have a mansion of a house.
Not everyone can even necessarily have a home theater room and these are things
that we can simulate to some degree in virtual reality.
Now the simulation is not as good as the real thing. Again,
if you are rich and you have your own home theater and mansion and private
island, good for you,
we may still be able to offer you the convenience of being able to
instantaneously get to different places.
But you're still probably not the people that are gonna benefit most from it.
But most of the people in the world aren't in that position.
Most of the people in the world live in relatively clamped quarters that are not
what they would choose to be if they had unlimited resources and the technology
curves for these things are,
this is $400 now we have an earlier one that's $200 that's less capable,
but these follow the cell phone price curves in many ways we have $25 cell
phones in India now bet our smartphones that do a lot of these things.
The technology curve,
Moore's law may be crapping out in terms of absolute performance,
but we've still got a lot of price performance that we can drive out of these
things and we can have virtual reality devices that can get cheap enough that
lots and lots of people will be able to have these and we can make better and
better software and it can be a better world in many ways. Now people,
everybody points towards like there's this art piece of art that goes around the
Internet of this sort of Dystopian kid in the corner, drew, you know,
drooling with glass goggles on with rainbow pictures on them and it's a terrible
looking place and people say it's like, oh,
this is the world you're trying to build.
People plugged into virtual reality that ignore the world around them.
And of course the first rejoinder to that is well,
is is life really better if he takes them off?
And he's in this horrible place there, but more concretely,
like I just came from in Dallas, it's a hundred degrees this week a there.
We changed the world around us in all that we do.
We live in air conditioning and people nowadays don't generally go, oh,
you're not experiencing the world around you because of your air conditioning.
You should be out there really experiencing the world.
Now that is what human beings do is we, we bend the world to our will.
And I think that a virtual reality that lets people do things that would not be
possible in the world or it comes down to it not economical and a lot of people
react negatively to any talk about economics,
but it is resource allocation. I am, you know,
you have to make decisions about where things go.
And I think that economically we can deliver more value to a lot of people in
this virtual sense.
We're at the very earliest stage of it right now with the experiences that we
have and the things you can do and how long you want to keep it on.
But there is a path to this comfortable thing that you can wear for hours at a
time. Maybe you spend your entire workday working in Ed.
Maybe your time after coming home is putting it on.
And I mean right now you can,
you can watch TV with someone else in virtual reality,
which is as mundane thing, but you can have I, you know,
your sister or somebody that's across the country and you could have meet in a
virtual space, look over and see each other, add, you know,
watch something on TV.
Like all activities that do not require an actual tactile physical thing can
eventually be subsumed in this where there are a lot of things that do require
the tactical stuff.
You're not going to be replacing food with virtual reality anytime soon,
but a surprising amount of things that people value are these largely audio
visual things. It's the decoration, the museum that you walk through.
You're not fondling the individual things there.
You're experiencing things in a way that could,
with a good enough virtual reality experience be replicated there without the
travel, without the lines, without the crowds.
You could have it private to yourself. And there's so many things like this.
It's not everything. It's to have your senses simulated fairly well.
But we can do an enormous amount with this.
And I always like internally, I'm almost a broken record in the company.
Most people are tired of hearing me harp about this,
but it's all about user value. You know what?
I care about building things as an engineer.
The whole point is to bring value to the world.
And I think that virtual reality can bring a lot of value. We're not there yet.
We're in very early days of,
there are certain niches of people today that can get a great value out of this.
I don't pretend that this is something that, you know,
everyone in the world can benefit from today,
but we're inching our way up towards that. And that's how, you know,
that's how the world gets better,
is by building technologies and distributing to them people so that they have
something better than they would have had if that didn't exist. John Carmack,
thank you for being you. Thank you. And thank you for everything you've done.
Thanks for being here as an honor.
I'm glad we finally got to do it and I really appreciate you. Alright, great.
Be Nice. Thanks. Thank you. Bye everybody.
[inaudible] [inaudible] okay.
[inaudible].